foreign
welcome to this new video by simply
learn digital marketing utilizes online
channels to promote products and
services reach Target audiences and
drive conversion it encompasses SEO sem
social media content marketing and email
marketing influencer or affiliate
marketing display ads mobile marketing
and data analytics marketers employ
strategies tailored to the digital
landscape for maximum visibility and
engagement
continuous adaptation to evolving Trends
is a crucial for Success the demand for
digital marketers is experiencing
continuous growth and is projected to
remain high in the foreseeable future
factors such as business increasing
focus on digital transformation the
rapid expansion of online advertising
the importance of data-driven marketing
the rise of social media and content
marketing the growth of e-commerce and
the advancement in mobile marketing
contribute to the strong demand for
skilled digital marketers top recruiters
are looking for digital marketing
manager SEO specialist SEO manager
social media manager social media
strategist content marketer content
strategist PPC specialist sem manager to
drive business growth and increase brand
popularity the digital marketing manager
salary in India ranges between 3 lakhs
to 18 lakh rupees per annum however in
U.S the salary ranges from 104 000
dollars two hundred and thirty thousand
dollars per annum so if you are looking
to become a digital marketing expert
then here we have post graduate program
in digital marketing so are you ready to
boost your career in digital marketing
then unlock your pathway to success in
the digital marketing realm with simply
learn's job assist program stand out
from the crowd and catch the attention
of the top hiring companies through a
joint Purdue simply learns digital
marketer certificate as a certificate
holder you will become eligible to join
the SDM Purdue University Alumni
Association expanding your network and
opportunities benefit from the master
classes delivered by Purdue faculty
offering invaluable insights and
strategies analyze real-world business
cases from Howard business publishing
and refine your skills with hands-on
experience in building websites and
executing digital marketing techniques
exclusive Master sessions by meta
blueprint trainers will provide expert
guide students while up to six credits
can be transferred towards the Purdue
online Ms in communication program
giving you an edge in further academic
Pursuits Unleash Your Potential and
embark on a rewarding digital marketing
career with this you can gain all the
necessary skills in return marketing
like website creation behavioral
marketing keyword research search engine
optimization search engine marketing
campaign management social media
marketing and much more with knowledge
of tools like SC ranking HootSuite chat
GPT Google ads Google Keyword Planner
Google train and there is much more on
the list don't miss out on this
incredible opportunity take action today
and enroll in our course to unlock the
secrets of digital marketing success
accelerate your career and gain the
skills you need to thrive in the
industry ready to get started click the
link in the description box and embark
on your journey to professional growth
and achievement hurry up spots are
filling up fast so without any further
Ado let's get started now let's see what
digital marketing is in simple words
digital marketing is the promotion of a
product or a brand through one or more
forms of electronic media such as
Internet mobile phones Google search
engine marketing Etc it's a way to reach
client on time and retain them with
interactive marketing using digital
Technologies also it is the most
accessible easy to use and contemporary
method of promotion which is also known
as online marketing
now let's look into digital marketing
versus traditional marketing several new
and old businesses are harnessing
digital marketing and rethinking their
marketing funnels in the age of digital
marketing a digital revolution has
reshaped how we live interact and
conduct businesses
traditional marketing seems to be losing
its relevance in today's era of
Technology knowing which marketing
method will work best for your business
is essential
traditional marketing methods such as
printing material radio and television
are quickly becoming outdated they are
too expensive ineffective and time
consuming however digital marketing is
the future of advertising now let's talk
about a few reasons why digital
marketing is a better choice than
traditional marketing
firstly there is a global reach a
website that allows you to find a new
market and trade globally for only a
small investment
lower cost a properly planned and
well-targeted digital marketing campaign
can reach the right customers at a much
lower cost than traditional marketing
methods
the next benefit is analytics several
tools are available to analyze and
report on marketing data collected
through digital channels and the data is
precious to any business now we are on
to our last benefit which is retargeting
suppose we have a website that sells
shoes and 100 people visit our website
but only to purchase the item
with the help of digital marketing we
can still Target those 98 visitors and
display our ads to them digital
marketing plays an essential role in
most businesses today this has led to an
increase in the demand for digital
marketing professionals because of this
many people are interested in learning
about digital marketing it is becoming
one of the essential skills that you can
have if you learn how to use it you can
make a difference in your marketing
capabilities hey everyone I am tusha
badiwal welcome to Simply learns YouTube
channel in this video we will discuss
the top 10 reasons to learn digital
marketing but before we begin if you
enjoy watching Tech related content
consider subscribing to our YouTube
channel and hitting that Bell icon to
stay tuned
so without any further delay let's get
started
easy to start a career a career in
digital marketing is an easy one to
start the field is growing rapidly and
there is a demand for professionals who
can care the digital assets of a company
with this in mind it is easy to find a
position even with no specific degree it
is also easy to find further training
and digital marketing as a lot of free
and paid resources are available
a technical and creative field both
Technical and creative skills are
necessary for digital marketing it has a
lot of subfield hence it requires a
unique skill set and knowledge of the
latest technology for example a social
media marketing professional should know
how to run a successful campaign digital
marketing is a perfect career option for
those who are interested in both the
creative and Technical fields
highly paid digital marketing is one of
the most popular and trending Industries
there is a vast demand for digital
marketing professionals as a result
digital marketing roles are also very
well paid your expertise could help you
gain better roles within your
organization which could improve your
salary according to Goldman sex report
digital marketing scope in the Indian
internet industry alone is expected to
reach us 160 billion by 2025 which shows
the extent of digital marketing in India
and the job demand for digital marketing
according to classdoor a digital
marketing manager earns around 7 lakh in
India and he she can earn roughly 1 lakh
23 000 dollars in the US
become an entrepreneur as a digital
marketer you will be familiar with wide
range of online tools and platforms you
can start a blog or website where you
can list your products or if you have
expertise in some field you can also
create your own digital products and
sell them online
also you can start your own freelancing
business where you can offer various
services to the clients all aspiring
entrepreneurs need to embrace digital
marketing and even the old ones need to
adapt in order to grow
career growth there are a lot of digital
marketing professionals around but very
few are skilled the demand for digital
marketing skills will increase in the
near future due to digital economies
rapid growth
many individuals are starting their
online businesses and almost every new
company starts with an online presence
hence it's a perfect chance for
individuals who are looking to make a
career in digital marketing
the next reason is versatility
digital marketing offers a variety of
career options and a lifetime learning
since there are so many aspects to it
for example suppose you worked in
content marketing for two years and now
you want to work in SEO
in that case there is relatively little
training you need so it won't be that
difficult to switch over if you want to
enter into some other domain your
digital marketing experience will always
be valuable therefore it is said that
digital marketers can easily change jobs
the next major reason is more number of
jobs several new jobs were created in
the digital marketing field after covet
as most businesses came online you will
find many digital marketing job
opportunities on LinkedIn every single
day Grandview research reports that the
global digital marketing software Market
size was USD 56 billion in 2021 and is
expected to grow at a compound annual
growth rate cagr of 19.1 percent from
2022 to 2013.
the field of digital marketing is washed
however digital marketing is also used
in other areas such as blockchain
blockchain provides trustworthy metrics
for monitoring marketing campaigns in
real time it's also a good chance for
digital marketers to discover other
fields like blockchain
time and cost effective in the long term
digital marketing will save you a lot of
time effort and money traditional
marketing is expensive and the cost keep
Rising there are cost of printing ads
television ads radio ads and billboards
digital marketing will give you more
profits than traditional marketing if
you know how to use it effectively
furthermore digital marketing requires
less efforts for example you can reach
Global audience using your laptop
sitting at home while traditional
marketing involves a lot of efforts
the next important reason is precision
proof job lending your dream job is a
rarity for many in the job market with
the economy still struggling businesses
are cutting jobs left and right so how
you can make yourself a session proof If
you are creative and willing to learn it
can happen there are many ways to make
yourself more desirable to businesses
and get job offers however one way is to
become an expert in digital marketing
digital marketing is the internet based
marketing of product and services using
digital Technologies mainly on the
internet
marketing is an integral part of any
business with the ever growing number of
Internet users it is expected that more
companies will use digital marketing
extensively in the future
so now let's discuss the last and
interesting reason specialization the
field of digital marketing has a wide
range of specializations SEO content
marketing influencer marketing SCM and
many other fall under digital marketing
an individual has a lot to explore and
once you explode you can pick a digital
marketing specialization according to
your interest additionally there is a
wide variety of skills that you need to
master under each of these categories
greetings everyone this is Rob Sanders
from Simply learn happy New Year and
today we're gonna talk about digital
marketing skills
so digital marketing allows business
owners regardless of the business
non-profit for-profit large or small
National local International to really
expand their business allows them to
personalize their content they could
save money and most importantly they can
measure the results and so that's what
we're going to focus on today when we
talk about digital marketing skills
focusing on measuring those results
so suppose anybody wants to work
in marketing or grow a company or help
grow an individuals company or ensure to
keep up with the appropriate skills this
is what we're going to cover today so
we're going to cover a few channels and
so let's get right to it today we're
going to start off with search engine
optimization or SEO
also known as organic search so SEO is
an interesting channel it's probably the
premier channel for most companies in
fact HubSpot confirms that 57 of B2B
marketers stated that SEO generates more
leads than any other marketing
initiative
so it's really important for not only
just generating traffic but it's also
important for generating leads and and
generating more business
including e-commerce and so what does
SEO entail and what skills should you
acquire in order to manage SEO as a
marketing channel
well if you think about it SEO is really
divvied up into two pies one pie is
called on page the other pie is called
off Pitch and so on page consists of
things you can do to the website to help
you
be found in organic search
so what are those things well it could
be anything from you know page load
speed to four or four errors to sitemaps
and so the point here is if you're going
to manage SEO and you know that you got
to make sure your website's in Tip-Top
shape or your clients websites and good
enough shape for Google to recognize it
as a legitimate site you have to have
some technical skills now I'm not saying
you have to be developer but at the same
time you have to know what a 4-4 error
is you know have to know where and how
to generate a site map and upload that
sitemap you need to know how to edit a
robot's text file so those are you know
what I call soft technical skills but
they're all valid for SEO so you have to
have some technical background
staying in the on page pie
okay you need to make sure you have not
only skills to write content but skills
to optimize content so you need to be
aware of all the different elements on a
page in order to optimize that page
so again that entails you know some
copywriting skills but more importantly
and probably more challenging is to take
those copywriting skills and enhance
them for SEO okay so making sure that
you're able to understand what it is
that you need to do to get a page
optimized so it can rank higher in the
search engine results so those are on
page skills
and then you got the other piece of the
pie which is off page so understanding
you know what it takes to make sure your
site is relevant so it's understanding
different metrics off page metrics like
page Authority domain Authority external
links internal links and so generally
most SEO managers have a third-party SEO
platform that they work with like
semrush or Moz so it's understanding how
to work with those platforms to measure
off-page results so
we always say that SEO as a digital
marketing channel is an 800 pound
gorilla well it is because you have on
page and off page to worry about so the
two of those together
you know is is quite a task in order to
rank
and so what brings SEO and all digital
marketing channels is understanding the
metrics and understanding what you're
seeing in order to measure results and
improve upon those results okay so
that's really the theme for all these
digital marketing channels we're going
to talk about today it's really about
okay what metrics and how do I measure
the results and so when we look at SEO
in terms of measuring results
on the on-page side okay you're going to
have to do some keyword analysis you're
going to have to understand okay what
volume is you're going to understand how
to get the competition numbers okay and
you're going to have to understand what
keywords to choose okay so that in
itself is a skill being able to choose
keywords based on several metrics then
you're going to have to be able to
ascertain you know what pages and what
keywords are driving traffic and how
those pages are performing
okay and then again the off page you got
different metrics like domain Authority
or page Authority we have external links
internal links you have no follow and
follows and and you allow these little
metrics related to off Pages yes you're
gonna have to understand what those
metrics mean and if you can understand
what those metrics mean and then more
importantly act on those metrics then
that's what's going to help you improve
your results in terms of SEO so again
that's going to be the common theme here
so I'm just going to highlight again
those metrics that you're going to need
to understand in order to better manage
SEO as a channel get on the on-page side
you need to understand the
technicalities involved but for example
page load what's a good page load time
what's a bad page low tongue from a
keyword perspective what's good volume
what's bad volume what's good
competition what's bad competition so if
you can understand the intricacies of
the measurements related to SEO then
that'll help you improve upon this big
Channel called organic search so SEO is
the practice of getting relevant traffic
to the website okay from organic search
results so it really is essential to
stay up to date
and have a complete knowledge of the
latest algorithm updates and factors
that affect search engine ranking
so that's SEO let's transition to search
engine marketing also known as paid
search sponsored search Google ads Bing
ads pay-per-click cost per click a lot
of acronyms a lot of ways to describe it
at the end of the day search engine
marketing means that hey you as an
Advertiser have the ability and have the
opportunity to rank at the very top of
the Google search results
now it's different than SEO because
you're actually paying for the placement
and so to be found at the top of the
search engine results
as a paid placement or sponsored ad
means that if somebody clicks on your ad
you're gonna pay Google X amount okay so
unlike SEO sem is very fast moving
and so when we talk about fast moving we
mean that you're collecting a lot of
data very quickly
so sticking with the theme of what
skills should I have for search engine
marketing well if you're going to
collect data then that means you need to
measure the results of that data and so
sticking with our theme of measuring
results you need to understand first and
foremost what all the different metrics
mean related to Central engine marketing
okay so I'm just going to Rattle off if
you will a few of the metrics but the
commonality here is
yes you can learn what those metrics
mean but you have to act on those
metrics so one of the the main metrics
involved with search engine marketing is
Impressions so impression is just
basically how many people have seen your
ad okay so if your ad shows up on the
search results page regardless of
whether somebody clicks on it or not
you're going to get an impression okay
so if you're getting a lot of
Impressions that means a lot of people
have seen your ad what's a lot of
impressions well it's objective okay so
it could be a thousand Impressions or
ten thousand Impressions at the end of
the day that's how many people have seen
your ad
now more importantly
you have another metric called clicks
clicks means how many people actually
saw your ad and then clicked on your ad
okay so if you have 100 people that have
seen your ad and one person who clicked
on your ad then you have a click through
rate of one percent
now when it comes to Google ads and
search engine Marketing in general you
want to have a high click through rate
especially on Google because that does
impact quality score so quality score is
another metric you need to be aware of
okay it's a quality score simply a
number between 1 and 10 that's assigned
to each keyword okay so what impacts
quality score click-through rate is one
of the factors that impact quality score
so if you have
200 or 300 or 500 or a thousand
Impressions and very little clicks that
means your click the rate is going to be
low if your click-through rate it's
going to be low then your quality score
is going to be low
and in order to pay less to Google you
need to make sure that your quality
score is good so you need to understand
the factors involved with quality score
you need to understand Impressions
clicks click-through rate because if you
don't have a good click-through rate
then how do you improve that so it's
about measuring the results and acting
upon the results those are the skills
involved with search engine marketing
and that's just on the click side you've
got the conversion side of the house so
you need to be able to understand how to
get conversions
and how to maintain a high conversion
rate so for example if you have a
hundred clicks
and only one conversion
that is a one percent conversion rate
okay fair enough but what are you paying
per conversion what's the cost per
conversion okay and if that number is
high like say twenty dollars and you're
only selling a product that's say ten
dollars
well then you got a problem and so
there's a lot of different metrics
involved with search engine marketing
you're collecting this data very quickly
so you need to be able to react to the
data that you see so that's the skill
set really involved with search engine
marketing if you're getting the data if
it's a low click-through rate or low
conversion rate or high cost per
conversion
or very low Impressions you need to be
able to understand how to react to what
you're seeing and what your data you're
collecting that to me is the primary
skill bottom line with search engine
marketing and there are other skill sets
involved don't get me wrong I mean it's
nice to be able to write copy because
with search engine marketing
typically the ads have very few
characters involved so you need to be
able to write a compelling ad to
convince somebody to click on your ad
and so writing coffee being able to
understand your target audience
um those are all things involved with
managing search engine marketing but
really the key component here is again
measuring the results okay let's switch
over to a traditional marketing channel
email marketing you know one of my
favorites you know listen we're all
bombarded with emails
uh and you know what it it becomes
cumbersome at times I mean it's easy to
just just regard an email and so to me
the key here if you're going to do email
marketing
you need to have a certain set of skill
sets and so what that skill set is is
really understanding your audience
because if you send an email to a
certain set of recipients
you need to hope that that email is
relevant to that audience okay so you
need to be able to really identify who
it is we're sending this email to
and a recent study done by statista
stated that 49 of consumers really like
to receive promotional emails from their
favorite Brands so if you have a very
strong brand then email marketing it's
probably a good channel for you if you
don't have a strong brand or nobody
really knows about your brand or your
product or your business then email
marketing could be a little bit of a
steeper Hill to climb if you will
but really email marketing is it
involves emails that promote the brands
products and services and if you could
Target the Right audience or making sure
you have the Right audience then you got
a good chance of having successful email
marketing campaigns
but when it comes to emails
you know it's like having a blank canvas
you can be as creative as you want as
long as you're talking to the audience
so the big skill set here again is
copywriting and having some you know
creativity involved with that
copyrighted saying the right things but
not saying too much at the same time
making the email aesthetically pleasing
as possible so that when somebody does
open the email
they're going to be able to react to it
so you know writing copy with strong
call to action or really relevant copy
that really talks to the audience I mean
those are all keys for email marketing
in my opinion
also one thing we didn't bring up in
search engine marketing but it certainly
holds true with search engine marketing
as well as email marketing and that's a
b testing and so a b testing has simply
taking an original and creating a
variant and testing the two to see which
one performs
well you could certainly do a b testing
with email marketing that means taking a
subject line
that has traditionally worked for you or
is relevant for that audience and then
creating
a variant or different subject line so
if I'm going to send an email to 100
people I'm going to send 50
people one subject line and then the
other 50 is going to get my variance
subject line and why is this important
because I want to be able to see what
people react to
okay so if I see the open rates higher
for the variant
versus the traditional or the original
subject line then I know that this
subject line works and therefore I'm
going to apply this subject line moving
forward and then what am I going to do
I'm going to take it and test it against
another variant so you should always do
a b testing on subject lines so the
concept of a b testing should not be
lost on any digital marketer okay
whether that be SEO search engine
marketing or email marketing so you
should have an understanding of a b
testing and of course going back to
measuring results with email you have a
different set of metrics we already
mentioned open rates so if you send out
100 emails how many people open the
email okay you want that open rate to be
as high as possible and then when they
open the email the people click on that
CTA or any of those links in the email
okay so you want a high click-through
rate and then more importantly when they
click on a link in the email they're
going to go to a landing page
you want that person to engage with that
landing page so what's the engagement
rate of the landing page from the email
okay so it's really important that you
have an understanding of all the
different metrics involved with email
marketing and again
how to react to that data so if you're
getting a low open rate could it be the
subject line isn't that good possibly
that's why you have to do testing if
you're getting a low click they're right
on the emails
that could be because the copy may not
be that great or the design or the call
to action or it's not compelling enough
for the recipient of the email and then
again the engagement on the landing page
if you have a low engagement rate a low
conversion rate
you got to look at that and figure out
how to improve that okay so you can
apply a B test in the landing page so
there are always ways to react to the
data regardless of what campaign or
regardless of what digital marketing
channel you're working in
so that's the commonality here one point
on email marketing is if you're going to
measure the results of the campaign
whether you're using you know vertical
response or MailChimp or you know some
other email marketing platform you want
to make sure you have what we call a UTM
tracking and if you're using Google
analytics having UTM tracking or
understanding what UTM tracking is
allows you to measure the results of
that email marketing campaign in Google
analytics so that's another skill set
you should have being able to apply you
know tracking to your digital marketing
campaigns including email
okay because if you don't it's going to
be hard to measure the results in Google
analytics so let's focus on one more
marketing channel here and that's social
media so we all know social media isn't
going anywhere it's becoming more and
more popular
in fact you know offshoot of social
media is really influencer marketing uh
you know if somebody an influencer has
millions of likes on say tick tock or
Instagram you might want to engage with
that influencer and help you promote
your brand or your product
in that really what social media is it's
a platform whether that be you know
Facebook or Twitter it's a it's a
platform to help you promote your brand
your product your services and it's a
chance for you to get to message your
user base your community prospective
clients people who don't even know about
your brand it's a chance to build
awareness so social media holds a lot of
different uh strategies if you will in
fact nearly almost 4 billion of the
world's population uses social media let
me say there's seven something billion
people in the world well that's a large
percentage a majority of the percentage
of the world uses a social media
platform okay in fact
just like SEO where you need an SEO
platform there are plenty of social
media platforms there's later there's
Sprouts social there's HootSuite there's
buffer in fact buffer confirms that 73
percent of marketers believe social
media marketing has been somewhat
effective or very effective for their
business and that's promising because
social media in my opinion
having been in this industry a while it
can be a very fickle Channel I mean if
you're trying to promote a product or
service on Facebook
and it's very very going to be very hard
to pull that person away who's engaged
with their Facebook feed
not only just to get them away from the
Facebook feed onto your website but then
to turn around and allow that person to
try and convert
okay based on what you have on your
website so it's challenging enough just
to get them away from the social media
platform let alone converting so that's
why when I say very fickle but you know
it's someone encouraging if Buffer's
telling us that marketers believe that
social media marketing can be effective
and it can be effective you just have to
have the right strategy so to me one of
the skill sets you should have if you're
going to be a social media marketing
manager is being able to understand you
know what is the strategy here what are
we trying to achieve
when we set up a social media platform
or enact a social media campaign
okay and so that's really the first
thing it's really understanding what
platforms what's the strategy here
because if the strategy is brand
awareness then what channels or social
media platforms if you will work best
for us is that Twitter is that Facebook
so it's being able to kind of formulate
a strategy a plan if you will for social
media marketing because the last thing
you want to do as a marketer is
endlessly just post content for the sake
of just posting content
because just like any other marketing
channel you're going to have metrics and
social media is not shy on the metric
front Okay so you have reach
you have Impressions you know engagement
rate in fact every social media channel
has its own set of specific metrics
whether that be likes followers shares
uh uh reviews Stars if you will so it
really depends on the social media
platform that you're using
but at the end of the day you need to be
able to measure the results if you're
posting let's just say on Facebook
and your whole
job or strategy is to entice engagement
meaning get people to share that
particular post or act on that post then
you need to be able to measure the
engagement how many people saw the post
how many people engaged with the post
okay and so just like any other
marketing channel you're collecting data
and you need to react to that data but
more importantly it's about being able
to you know put a strategy together
first
and then I would you know a skill set I
would recommend you have is
understanding all the different social
media platforms that are out there you
know I just didn't buffer or HootSuite
or Sprout social they're all good in
their own right but they're all going to
have different features so to me
understanding what social media platform
works best for you you want to choose a
social media platform that you know
allows you to control what posts you
schedule when you schedule them how
they're scheduled what platform they're
scheduled on
at the same time you want a social media
platform that's going to help you
understand the engagement that you're
getting from that platform
and you'll probably want a social media
platform that allows you to quote
unquote listen in if you will on what
users are you know reacting to in terms
of hashtags or what's trending on that
particular platform
okay so you want to listening tool if
you will uh as part of that social media
platform so it's understanding what
platform you want to use when it comes
to social media marketing it's
understanding what strategy that that
platform is going to help you when they
enact okay and then it's also that
social media platform that's going to
help you understand the data so you can
react to the data
so those are all to me the skill sets
you need as a social media manager and
then
an offshoot of social media is paid
social so just like search engine
marketing you can advertise on say
Twitter LinkedIn Facebook on a cost per
click basis meaning if you're showing
your ad on LinkedIn and somebody clicks
on it you're gonna pay
for that click you're going to pay
LinkedIn or you're going to pay Twitter
you're going to play Facebook so it's
understanding you know the skill sets
involved with paid social is
understanding what assets you can have
when advertising on these platforms you
know can you use video on LinkedIn or
Facebook
um you know can you use what type of
images and you know how big do those
images need to be and can you have
wording on those images or what are the
guidelines involved with having images
as part of your ads
so having a full understanding of the
types of assets that you can run in
terms of your advertising on social
media is very important in my opinion
because it's always changing and you
want to be able to put the best asset
the best message you want to put your
best foot forward when advertising on
social media and of course when you do
advertise again a whole another set of
metrics you know how many people saw
you're at how many people clicked on
your ad how many people engage with the
landing page how many people converted
what was the cost per conversion so all
of those are metrics that we covered in
search engine marketing they apply with
paid social
so you have the opportunity on paid
social you have the opportunity on
social media
to really get your message out there
it's really understanding what kind of
data you're collecting what are the
results of the ad or the post and how do
you react to that and that's really the
common theme with digital marketing
skills if you're not a big fan of
numbers you're not a big fan of excel if
you will or spreadsheets if looking at a
mountain of data scares you
well then you might want to think
otherwise when going into digital
marketing but if you want to embrace the
data
then digital marketing is really a great
career because if you can get the data
and you know how to react to the data
then you can be successful in any
campaign you run right that should do it
for today thanks for joining look
forward to reaching out to you for more
of these webinars feel free to email us
or go check out our website at
simplylearn.com thank you so much and
I'll see you soon now we have reached
the most exciting and essential part of
the video every salary of a digital
marketing manager in the digital
marketing industry there is a huge
demand for digital marketing managers
and their salaries reflect that several
factors determine the income a person
can expect including experience the size
of your company your location and your
industry digital advertising has proven
to be more convenient and effective than
traditional advertising since most of
your audience is online as a result
digital marketing is growing and
becoming more popular a digital
marketing manager plays a significant
role in drawing Revenue into the
business and due to their highly result
driven nature their salaries are high
register marketing managers earns
approximately 6 lakh 72 000 per year in
India and in the US he or she can earn
roughly 75 000 per year
lastly let's discuss the future of
digital marketing Grandview research
reports that the global digital
marketing software Market size was USD
56.52 billion in 2021 and is expected to
grow at a compound annual growth rate
cagr of 19.1 percent from 2022 to 2030.
you have looked into the new digital
marketing trends at some point if you
are aspiring or experienced digital
marketer the best way to succeed in
digital marketing is to keep up with
current trends in the field now we will
look at the two trending technologies
that use digital marketing and are on
the rise blockchain the data from
digital advertising campaign can
sometimes be inaccurate so Improvement
can be difficult monitoring marketing
campaigns in real time is achievable
with blockchain for obtaining
trustworthy metrics top brands such as
Unilever are applying blockchain for
improving digital advertising efficiency
successfully
augmented and virtual reality stock box
Nivia and Volkswagen all launched
successfully AR and VR campaigns to
better connect their brands and products
to their customer it is undeniable that
these two technologies are booming and
expected to grow massively in the next
few years the use of digital marketing
in these Technologies makes us aware the
bright future of digital marketing so
when we want to go and promote our
product or service using a campaign we
have different options so there are
different types of digital marketing
channels that we can choose from and
let's just go through that list of
digital marketing channels and the first
one is what I consider the king of them
all and that's SEO so SEO stands for
search engine optimization there's
search engine marketing there's email
marketing affiliate marketing social
content mobile and then we can get into
subsets of each of these digital
marketing channels but really we'll
start with SEO because that's the king
and to me that's basically increasing
the quality and quantity of relevant
organic traffic on the search engines
including Google so depending on where
you're located in the U.S market Google
tends more has a large market share so
you want your pages on your website to
be found and clicked on organically and
so that means if somebody types in a
keyword you want that relevant page to
show up first on Google so somebody can
click on that link okay and we know that
millions of people specifically in the
US but worldwide you search on a daily
basis so if you're ranking for those
relevant keywords you can imagine how
much traffic you can get okay so that's
SEO okay and here's an example so you
type in online shopping well you can see
the first listing here is a paid search
ad I'm going to get to that in a minute
the second organically is Amazon okay so
online shop shopping you think maybe
Walmart you think maybe Alibaba or
you're thinking probably Amazon okay so
no surprise Amazon's ranking for the
keyword online shopping and so if
somebody clicked on their listing that's
traffic for Amazon let's move on to
search engine marketing you know known
as sem or pay-per-click or cost per
click or PPC or CPC or sponsored search
or Google ads I mean there's a lot of
different names synonymous with sem so
search engine marketing is really just
using paid ads on search engines just as
we saw the previous example if you want
to be found for keyword you don't have
to worry about organic if you're willing
to pay for it you just bid on that
keyword and voila you have the
opportunity to appear number one in the
search results at the top of the page
for that keyword now when somebody
clicks on it you have to pay Google if
it's Google you're advertising on but
that's the beauty of search engine
marketing you can bid on keywords and
appear at the top of the search results
for that keyword example here if we go
back to online shopping well myus.com is
bidding on that keyword online shopping
so they're actually appearing above
Amazon's organic listing but that's what
they want to do they want to be found
for that keyword so if they're not
ranking for it organically well they're
bidding on it and if somebody happened
to clicked on that listing then myus.com
is going to pay Google something
depending on what the cost per click is
and so that could be anywhere from one
penny to a hundred dollars it depends
depends on the keyword depends on who
else is bidding on the keyword depends
on the location depends on the time of
day depends on quality score there's a
lot of factors involved I'm regarding
what you pay however the benefit of sem
is visibility and getting traffic to
your website for keywords you're not
found for so that's why sem's such a
popular choice for a lot of companies
okay let's talk about digital marketing
that's a traditional type of digital
marketing channel it's been around a
long time you know we all send emails on
a daily basis and we probably all
receive emails on a daily basis just an
effective way to capture leads and
convert them to customers because with
email you can personalize your emails
and you can send your emails to a
segmented audience okay so if you have
emails from females who are 35 years of
age to 44 that live and say this
southern part of the United States you
can segment that send them an email and
cater that email directly to that
audience and of course you can put some
nice call to action in there you can
design Planet really snazzy and you
could track it just like you can any
other digital marketing channel so email
is a very effective way to really reach
a target audience because everybody for
the most part has a functioning email
account so basically here's an example
of an email that could go out if you're
selling a product and like products
promotion is about to end well you know
get that email out to your target
audience let them know hey you have
until tonight to purchase a product and
if you purchase it you're gonna get 30
off and you can put the coupon code
right in there with a nice call to
action and you can measure how many
people click on that email go to that
web page and purchase the product using
that coupon code so that's an example of
email marketing okay we have affiliate
marketing so affiliate marketing is an
effective way for digital marketers to
basically create a sales force of people
so basically what you're doing is you're
getting gain Merchants to promote your
products and services and you're using
usually a third-party broker like
Commission Junction or cj.com as an
example to introduce you the the person
selling the product the merchant with
the affiliate so that affiliate could
likely be a merchant him or himself and
they can basically be a good partner of
yours by publishing your product or
service on their website so that they
can sell in order to get commissions so
it's all based on a commission so you
basically are going to use a third-party
affiliate like CJ get all these
Affiliates to work for you they're going
to promote your product or service if
they do sell your product or service
you're going to pay them a commission
that's more or less how it works with
affiliate marketing and you know with
affiliate marketing to me it's a good
way to you know really promote your
product or service and you can pick and
issues the Affiliates or the Publishers
of whom you want to work with so here's
an example of affiliate marketing at
work okay you basically see a banner
basically you can see earn up to 12
advertising fees with a trusted
e-commerce leader okay so if somebody
clicked on that purchased for example or
joined you could pay out that commission
okay let's turn our attention to social
media marketing so social media
marketing you know I wouldn't say it's
fairly new I mean if I think about it
we're in 2019 and I remember talking
about Facebook back in 2006 so you're
talking about 13 14 15 years of social
media it's definitely evolved over the
years and but the concept Remains the
Same it involves creating different
types of content depending on the
platform okay so you could be on
Pinterest or Instagram and be dealing
with photos or you could be on Twitter
tweeting out certain characters up to a
limit okay and so it really depends on
the social media platform uh that really
drives the type of content you're going
to promote but we know social media can
be effective because people use social
media I mean Facebook is one of the more
popular platforms and if you want to get
your product or service out there you
could certainly pay to have an ad on
Facebook or you could just post your
content organically okay that's the
beauty of social most of your Social
platforms like LinkedIn and Twitter and
Facebook and Pinterest and Instagram
they all have a paid form of advertising
that you can use to promote your product
or service or you can go the organic
route and you know post content
organically in hopes of driving traffic
back to your website so with social you
do have two options here but social is
interesting because a lot of different
social media platforms out there it
really depends on your product or
service okay so an example of social
media marketing especially on Facebook
with Facebook you got mobile and desktop
and you obviously have the opportunity
to post something organically and have
that liked or commented on or shared or
you can post an ad and get that liked
commented or shared or clicked and have
people go back to your website and
fulfill the goal of what you want them
to do so moving on to content marketing
it's a Content marketing is really an
effective way of really Distributing
valuable content online and when we talk
about content marketing you know we're
talking about different types of assets
so it could be simply text in the form
of a blog post or it could be a video or
it could be an infographic or it could
be an image okay there are lots of ways
to create content these days especially
in digital marketing and the great thing
about content marketing is you're
writing content for a targeted audience
so if you're trying to Target an
audience on say Instagram then you know
who your audience is and you know what
the type of content you're going to post
on there so it could be in the form of a
video or infographic or just a graphic
and so that's the beauty of content
marketing really putting yourself out
there
um and depending on the platform putting
yourself out there with various types of
content so for example if we look at
YouTube you can see this video here
about digital marketing certified
associate well hey you don't need to
always write the content you can produce
the content in the form of a video and
post it on YouTube this is a form of
content marketing so that's content
marketing and then let's talk about
mobile marketing so content marketing
again different types but if we go now
to mobile marketing you can kind kind of
segue from content to mobile because the
only difference here is with mobile it's
strictly on mobile phone it's not
desktop so mobile marketing is really a
strategy on its own that helps you the
company promoting your product or
service to reach your target audience
through a mobile device and that
includes tablets and how you could do
that is via messaging you could do it
via email or you could be do it via an
app okay so you have different ways of
getting your content out there to people
okay so as an example you can use
basically SMS or instant messaging via
mobile devices to promote your product
or service here's another example of a
mobile marketing via app install and so
you can even compound that by running a
say Google ad as an example and running
your Google ad on say just mobile you
can do a bit adjustment just for mobile
and the goal could be app installs okay
so and you can even do a mobile or app
extension so there's lots of ways to
really promote your app or your product
or your service Via mobile marketing
Rachel is a baker who runs her own
Bakery to expand her business she
decided to create an online presence by
first setting up a Blog she began
posting on her blog regularly however
even after regularly posting on the blog
there were barely any visitors showing
up deciding not to give up Rachel began
searching for a solution on the internet
that's when she came across SEO or
search engine optimization a term she's
never heard before
so let's take a journey together and
help her learn about SEO search engine
optimization is a method that could
improve the quality and quantity of the
audience coming to Rachel's website from
search engines it could increase brand
awareness attract local customers and
build credibility and trust and all of
this is possible without having to spend
a single penny to bring visitors to our
website Rachel would have to take
advantage of the two types of SEO
on-page and off-page SEO Rachel first
decides to tackle on-page SEO and get
that sorted on-page SEO involved Rachel
optimizing her website both in terms of
content and the technical aspects
including the HTML source code schema
meta Tags and More she started off by
using tools like Google AdWords allref
and semrush to identify popular Search
terms associated with the recipes she
planned to publish on her blog she began
to look for Search terms related to the
broader area of baking cooking and
related topics once she found these
Search terms she began to incorporate
them into her recipes she started off by
providing an introduction to the recipe
with this she could provide an engaging
beginning to her story like how the dish
reminded her of her childhood and
enabled her to naturally include the
Search terms into the blog she also
included these keywords in the actual
recipe as well additionally she added
pictures videos time lapses and more to
increase credibility and engagement for
her content and subsequently persuading
search engines to show her content to
more people after this she moved to the
website metacontent that search engines
display when her blog appears in search
results
optimize The Meta tax alt tags header
Tags and More this completed the on-page
aspect of SEO thanks to this she saw a
significant increase in the number of
visitors coming to her page having done
all she could on her webpage she now
decides to explore what could be done
off page to improve her Page's
visibility on search engines off-page
SEO involved Rachel doing things outside
her site page to help increase its
search engine rankings
making optimizations outside the site
would improve the site's popularity
relevance trustworthiness and Authority
this is possible with the help of
reputable websites vouching for your
content with backlinks social media
marketing guest blogging linked unlinked
brand mentions influencer marketing and
much more
Rachel also understood that for her
content to reach people she would have
to promote it on social media platforms
like Facebook Twitter and Instagram as
well as Niche platforms like quora
Reddit and medium these could help her
achieve greater reach for her website by
sending stronger social signals to
search engines
leading to the page being shown as
highly relevant for related searches and
audiences and even after understanding
and implementing all of this Rachel had
just scratched the surface of what was
possible with SEO
before we find out what she did next
let's have a look at a quiz which of the
following is the most effective way to
improve off-page SEO one creating plenty
of web pages of a Content 2. getting
backlinks from relevant and
authoritative sites three acquiring
backlinks through link Buy
4. none of the above let us know your
answer in the comments section below for
a chance to win an Amazon voucher now
let's go back to Rachel Rachel decided
to take up simplylearn's digital
marketing certification with classes
covering just about everything she
needed to know about SEO it was only a
matter of time before Rachel began to
implement her learnings on her website
and see a massive uptick in the number
of viewers coming to her website in time
she could even earn money off the site
by setting up an online shop and with
that we've covered an introduction to
the concepts of SEO and the
possibilities it can open for you either
as a marketer or a business owner so if
you are looking to become a digital
marketing expert then here we have post
graduate program in digital marketing so
are you ready to boost your career in
digital marketing accelerate your career
and gain the skills you need to thrive
in the industry ready to get started
click the link in the description box
and embark on your your journey to
professional growth and achievement
hurry up spots are filling up first
welcome to today's session
I am Sachin sehgal and I am here to talk
about a very important tool Google ads
what is Google ads
Google ads is a online platform or an
interface or a tool we can say or a
software which is developed by Google to
help the advertisers to run different
kind of ads on different publishing
sites or publishing platforms
if I make it more simple for you suppose
you are an Advertiser and you sell a
digital marketing course
so you know that the bulk of the traffic
would come from Google because this is
the most used search engine in the world
so when we type this we see lot of
results here
and when we start a website it is very
difficult to rank organically or free or
through the SEO on the very first few
pages
with the help of Google ads in a very
starting days we can rank on the top
like
this this this
[Music]
or this Advertiser so these are the four
top positions which right now has been
given to the advertisers who are playing
or who are running their ad using Google
ads on a first page we see seven of such
ads four on the top I've shown you and
three on the bottom
so these are the maximum placements
which we see on a Google search page
this is the first kind of AD which can
be created under the Google ads tool
which we would definitely going to learn
today how to create such beautiful ad
copy second ad which generally we see on
different
sides like if I'll open any new site if
I'll open any block site if I open a
site like a speed test.net then you
would see a beautiful banner or a
responsive ad like these these and these
okay how come I am able to say that
these are ads so if you'll just hover on
this this would say ads by Google
ads by Google so a different Advertiser
this is a Paramount this is from GoDaddy
and the publishing site which has been
selected by these advertisers is
speedtest.net
the Third Kind of AD which we generally
see on Google itself but in a different
colors and shape is called shopping ad
so if I just search suppose I want black
formal
shoes
then
the add copy is changed it is not
like a text ad which we have seen
earlier
though there is no text ad in this
search but we have just seen in the case
of digital marketing course
but it is an ad we can see from here
okay so this is called a shopping ad
then if I go and if I open
YouTube
and if I'll search a term maybe I am in
a search of email
for beginners course
and if I just play any of the videos a
random one
and before the video place
yes certainly we can skip after
five to six seconds and sometimes we see
a ad which streams but cannot be skipped
so these are video ads which again
created by this beautiful tool Google
ads one more ad Mobile Installation but
I cannot show you as I am from the
desktop though I would able to show you
the
screenshot of the same
now coming to the part why Google ad is
so important okay so I'll be just quick
now because we have to be making the
account today and also the campaign
Google ad is important in many ways
because Google ad helps us to increase
the visibility of our products increase
the visibility of our brand because you
can just imagine you were there on
Google but you were somewhere on Sixth
page or probably you know in the next
page generation if I'll just go and not
beyond that there are the results but
suppose you are you are on the sixth
page so we can just assume that nobody
goes beyond first or second I don't know
if you or not but I don't go okay and
that's how the service is 97 percent of
people doesn't go beyond first to second
page so that means we have to be on a
first page if you really want to sell
our products so increasing that
visibility of our brand
would take time if we just keep waiting
for SEO results to come or to give us
the first page or a second page ranking
so for that reason for our quick results
by making a relevant ad copy and by
targeting the right keywords we can
increase availability we can increase
the brand awareness we can increase the
traffic
okay we can also use a beautiful way of
retargeting or a remarketing where
people are able to recall our brand or
able to make the decisions if at a first
time they were not actually taken
suppose I say they went to my site
or any of the sides but in a very first
time they have not given me a result so
for me as this website the result is
getting the lead form field this is a
lead form and this is the page where we
have reached and where wherever you know
you would see a relevant page connected
to the particular ad that page is called
a landing page okay so this landing page
has a Content this landing page has an
objective to get the form field and this
landing page has a CTA which is called a
call to action okay so for me as an
Advertiser or as a digital marketer or
as a campaign manager of this brand did
you perform it's very important to get
as many as people to this page plus it
is the most important part that I get
lot of form field and lot of CPA clicks
or this call to action clicks but every
time I cannot assume I have to be
realistic as well if even hundred or
thousand users have landed to my website
from the ad I cannot expect more than
three to five percent conversions okay
so if I say suppose 100 users have
reached my page today since morning so I
can only expect three to five percent of
leads or three to five users would have
filled the data but when we talk about
the remarketing then it is about
retargeting those guys who have reached
here but did not
filled up the data or did not convert it
or in the same case if I have taken them
to the black formal shoes site they
reached to the landing page or a product
page but did not bought the product so
for that reason we can always retarget
them using the website data so all these
things are very important once we start
learning Google ads deeply then you
would know how these works like you know
how the functionality of of these works
like okay so they are talking about the
same thing rlsa is retargeting list of
search ads we are able to Target people
who have not converted okay who have not
converted okay
then it is also used for
um I think I've talked about branding
now they're talking about how these
strategies work like so we generally
work on the different bid uh strategies
like how you pay to Google so the most
important one when it comes to Google
search ad this is called search art or
techstart is CPC so CPC is cost per
click okay now I'm talking about a very
important technical term the very first
technical term probably we have just
talked uh about the broadness off of the
Google ads how that is you know
important to increase The Branding
visibility and traffic we did talked
about the remarketing a bit but now I am
getting into the campaign terms which is
going to be very important if you want
to learn today how to create a search
camp in a search art so the very first
thing is bidding strategy so we pay CPC
or it is also called PPC when we are
running doing this sort of an ad which
is called text ad this means cost per
click or pay per click so when somebody
clicks on this clicks on this clicks on
this as a user as a Searcher as a viewer
then only
Advertiser would pay to Google
this is what PPC means pay per click
marketing so Advertiser is getting an
advantage that till the time the ad has
only been shown
he is not paying any Penny to Google but
the movement a very first user comes and
clicks on it then the amount of certain
bid value starts deducting from the
advertisers Google ads account which we
certainly going to be creating for you
guys as well in a while okay so you
create a Google ads account you put some
money into it you start running the ad
of different sort text ad Banner ad
video ad shopping ad and the movement
somebody clicks or somebody watches a
video or somebody takes any action on
your ads then only you pay most of the
times okay that is what the CPC strategy
works like
then also it is a very important part
that we should know how we are measuring
the results so in anywhere in the
digital marketing if you talk from my
experience I know we are only able to
get better results or we are only able
to get more conversions if we are just
not earning the ad we have to be first
researching how the ads should be
created we have to be working on the
areas which should not be filled uh we
should not be left unfilled and it
should be focused on the audience it
should be focused on certain
parameters and after running the ad also
it is very important to keep measuring
the performance and optimizing
optimizing and optimizing further or
otherwise taking care in the next
campaign okay so I think superficially
we have talked about a lot of things on
a go why not just to get into the Google
ads now see how the account is created
for free and then let's make a campaign
first and we'll come back and we
understand we'll try to understand some
of the important things like you know
there are metrics which we have to be
seeing there are formats okay so for
mats I've already talked about okay so
this is the text that I've already shown
then there is a banner ad which I've
shown you on the uh you know
speedtest.net there is another kind of
an ad image that again you know you see
on a different platforms like websites
and apps then there is a app ad which I
could not show you practically because I
am logged in from my desktop so this was
the fifth kind of an ad which I was
talking about a Mobile Installation ad
so this probably you see only on most of
the time on a mobile because as an
Advertiser he would want that
installation Button as a CTA should be
directly placed under the ad so that if
person searches for something on a
mobile then the ad is directly showing
them the installation button and the app
can be downloaded into their mobile
gadgets okay so now then there is a
video ad which we already seen in the
shopping ad I've already shown you okay
then there's a another ad which is just
a call only though it is again you know
created by the Google ads only we will
see what is email marketing well email
has been around for a very long time of
course and in the very early days there
wasn't an email marketing service that
you could use yeah you couldn't easily
send out hundreds of emails so what you
did you were actually using the BCC or
the blind carbon copy in your email
system system to send out emails to many
people of course the I.T Department of
companies in those early days they
didn't like that because it would block
the email system of the company so they
come up with little marketing email
Marketing Solutions on the company's
Mainframe but it was all very inflexible
you had to take your email you had to
take your mailing list give that to the
guy in the IT department and if you're
lucky then maybe in a couple of days
later your email would be sent you
wouldn't get any data at all about those
emails yeah you knew how many emails
were sent but you didn't know who would
have opened an email or who would have
clicked on the email
nowadays of course things are completely
different yeah now you have email
marketing where you can use email
service providers who offer you lots of
tools and lots of analytics to manage
and plan and measure your email
marketing campaigns
so what actually is email marketing it
uses email addresses from people to
inform your email list about your
product or service we call these
commercial emails which is completely
different of course from the billions of
personal emails that are being sent yeah
around the the internet every day so
this is a commercial email that you sent
to an email list about your product your
service or a newsletter and what have
you
Additionally you can integrate it into
your marketing automation so you can and
it can help your customers to see your
latest products and offers and you can
obviously use the email list to and
persuade them to buy your book a demo or
sign up for a trial or register for an
event
yeah we call this email nurturing where
you can send a range of emails to take
people through the Journey to help them
to make the decision
so what are the different uses of email
marketing it can be used in relationship
building with existing customers who
bought a product for instance sentiments
thank you email it could be to boost
brand awareness it could be about
promoting various pieces of content it
can help you in generating leads or to
promote or Market your products and very
important you can use it to nurture
leads social media marketing actually
means what is it yeah and we got to put
this in the context of the definition of
marketing
I studied Marketing in the very early
days in the 80s and my main sort of Guru
in marketing was Philip kotler and over
the years marketing has sort of
developed from traditional marketing to
online marketing but the basic concept
has not changed if you look at the
definition of marketing it's the
activity of creating
communicating
delivering and exchanging offerings
that have value for customers
yeah so you supply you deliver you
exchange products or services that have
a value for your customers
so two very important aspects here there
is value and there is customer and that
is what we capture in the marketing
concept you put the customer at the core
of what you do
yeah because when you do that you
automatically will look at what value
are we giving to the customer
yep so take social media marketing in
that context
then the second part of the social media
marketing
sort of term is the word social media
what is social media when I explain
social media I'm using the three C's the
three C's of social media marketing and
they are content they're community and
campaigns
content is the fuel of your social media
content is the
um the currency of social media if you
have really good content that you can
share on the internet
you're using various multiple multiple
social media channels like Facebook like
YouTube or like video or like Instagram
or blogging you name it yeah people will
engage with your content
and then when people start engaging with
your content they may come back for more
content that you supply and they will
then become part of your community so
Community is a very important aspect of
your social media definition
with really good content you can create
communities
and then you can push that process by
running campaigns
yeah and a campaign makes it relevant
for businesses
because when you run a campaign you have
a goal for your campaign you have an
objective you have a star date you have
an end date
yep and that is what social media
marketing is it's all about running
campaigns to develop your communities
with really exciting content
and then you put it into the marketing
context you do that if it's a customer
at in the core of what you do
yes so if I then take that to a
definition of social media marketing
is
very basic it says the use of social
media to develop a company's brand
increase website traffic and boost sales
that is what we call social media
marketing
yeah the most important aspect here is
that you need to have an outcome you
need to have a result which is customer
related
and that is where the sales element
comes in you do this to get the customer
to do something and in the end that is
buying your product or your service
yeah so social media marketing is not
the Tactical
combination of your social media
networks you had to
um to reach as many people that needs to
be a goal to it and when we talk about
marketing it comes down to selling your
product or service with a value
yeah so that HD
um kind of the call to action as it were
that comes out of your social media
marketing so keep that in mind
everything you do with your social media
marketing in the end comes down to
reaching your goals or achieving your
objectives of developing your company's
brand increasing website traffic or
growing your sales
now a big benefit that you're getting
these days in digital marketing and
social media marketing is data
is intelligence
is knowledge
in the early days of marketing the
biggest problem has always been how to
measure the success of your marketing
campaigns if I ran adverts in a magazine
how do I measure the effectiveness if I
do a PR campaign and they write about me
in the newspaper how do I measure the
effectiveness of that how can I track
that when somebody buys a product it
actually is as a result of the pr
campaign that I ran
so in the early pre-internet days yeah
we the only way to measure
customer engagement as it were were
through Loyalty cards or credit cards
yeah with a loyalty card you had some
basic customer data through credit cards
you could track transactions but it's
very difficult to relate it to your
marketing then the internet emerged and
all of a sudden I could track traffic to
my website
yeah I could see how many people visit
my website are these people that visit
my website for the first time are they
returning visitors what are the most
popular pages that they see how long do
they stay on my website and are they
actually buying my products
yeah so that was a major advancement of
marketing in the early 2000s and then
when social media emerged it all of a
sudden became possible to measure
engagement
how many people are having conversations
with us I could even measure sentiments
are people positive about my brand are
they negative about my Brands I could
track the effectiveness of my marketing
campaigns
I could measure the effectiveness of my
advertising campaigns that I ran online
so today's reality is that we can
measure everything
we can measure clicks we can measure
transactions we can measure engagements
we can measure return on investments
yeah and we can now even take that a
step further through artificial
intelligence that we can actually start
making predictions how people may
respond to campaigns that we're going to
be running
this is Shruti from Simply learn welcome
to this content marketing full course by
simply learn we'll begin this full
course by understanding what content
marketing is and some of its popular
strategies then we will see how content
marketing affects SEO and we'll
understand how to rank number one on
Google and YouTube by creating high
quality content
then we will look into the top 10
important content marketing interview
questions and answers at the end we will
look into minor Concepts like a simple
beginner's guide to content marketing
and introduction to content marketing
certification training by the end of
this video I can assure you that all
your content marketing career related
queries would have been answered for
this training with me I have our
experienced content marketing specialist
Rob and Greg jaboo together they will
take you through the various topics of
content marketing so without any further
Ado let's get started before we begin
make sure to subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss an update from Simply learn
I'm Greg jarbo and what is that I mean
what we're going to talk about in this
first module of a Content marketing
Foundation course is literally content
marketing
um okay what is it so content marketing
Is Not A New Concept it's been around
for over a hundred years in fact one of
the classic Foundation stories of you
know the birth of content marketing goes
all the way back to the Michelin
Brothers in France and the Michelin
Brothers you know in case you haven't
done your history that's okay you know a
little refresher right now
were two brothers who made pneumatic
tires and they were trying to sell them
along with an Innovative product at its
time called the automobile
in an era where the roads were horrible
in a place France where frankly people
didn't like to get outside of Paris and
into uh provinces because my God what
was worth going out there for you know
or Paris that's all Happening Here and
what the Michelin Brothers realized is
if they wanted to sell more tires
they had to get people to drive farther
and farther
than use them
so what did they come up with
the concept that really is the birth of
content Marketing in my book
was the Michelin guide
and the Michelin guide was unique in
that it reviewed restaurants not just
restaurants nearby in Paris but
restaurants out there in the provinces
and the Michelin brothers are the ones
who came up with the one two and three
star rating system to say this
restaurant I know it's way out there
it's you know bad roads but guess what
to die for the Ratatouille oh you you
gotta have it this is a three-star
restaurant you you it's worth making the
trip
and oh by the way and since we're going
to give you a guide and you have to get
out of Paris in order to get there we're
going to tell you where you can find
gasoline along the way uh which hotels
uh you might want to stay at overnight
and oh by the way just in case you have
to
how to repair a flat tire particularly
if it's a Michelin tire because it's a
Pneumatic and you know what it's quite
easy to repair
and guess what that put Michelin on the
map why they weren't trying to sell you
more tires
they weren't telling you about the
features and benefits of round
or tire repair I mean that was in there
but it was only a how-to article not
necessarily a feature and benefit
what they were doing was they were
speaking to Their audience about what
Their audience was truly passionate
about which in Paris in 1900. was food
and by creating content
we got the audience to get into their
new Innovative automobile
and drive all the way out there into the
provinces for that absolutely remarkable
three-star restaurant
people got more Flats people had to
replace their tires but it was worth it
and oh by the way
Michelin sold more tires
so that that's a great story every time
you sort of
you know hit a pause and like well we
were doing content marketing and we need
to come up with a concept
back to the Michelin guide it's it's
great Foundation
let's go
to a modern definition where are we now
in the 21st century
when it comes to content marketing
well you can read the slide here and
read the definition and some people like
reading definitions I'm not going to
read it to you but I am going to
highlight a couple of words in the
definition that I think are absolutely
critical to any definition
of content marketing
the content that you create needs to be
relevant
and it also has to be valuable
now if it's not relevant then you're not
actually meeting my needs or interests
you know and why would I be interested
in them and we've gotten way too tired
I'm screening out the commercial that
comes on
um you know trying to sell out snow
tires and pardon me we live in Florida I
don't use the tires what the what the
heck is this commercial doing
you know interrupting what I'm watching
so relevance is important
relevance means that this content isn't
going to get screened out
and the valuable the valuable can can
work in a lot of different ways it can
be interesting
it can be useful
you know value is an interesting
proposition all by itself content
marketing
um okay what is it so content marketing
Is Not A New Concept it's been around
for over a hundred years in fact one of
the classic Foundation stories of you
know the birth of content marketing goes
all the way back to the Michelin
Brothers in France and the Michelin
Brothers you know in case you haven't
done your history that's okay you know a
little refresher right now
were two brothers who made pneumatic
tires and they were trying to sell them
along with an Innovative product at its
time called the automobile
in an era where the roads were horrible
in a place France where frankly people
didn't like to get outside of Paris and
into the provinces because my God what
was worth going out there for you know
or Paris that's all Happening Here
and what the Michelin Brothers realized
is if they wanted to sell more tires
they had to get people to drive farther
and farther
and use them
so what did they come up with
the concept that really is the birth of
content Marketing in my book
was the Michelin guide
and the Michelin guide was unique in
that it reviewed restaurants not just
restaurants nearby in Paris but
restaurants out there in the provinces
and the Michelin brothers are the ones
who came up with the one two and three
star rating system to say this
restaurant I know it's way out there
it's you know bad roads but guess what
to die for the Ratatouille ugh you you
gotta have it this is a three-star
restaurant you you it's worth making the
trip
and oh by the way and since we're going
to give you a guide and you have to get
out of Paris in order to get there we're
going to tell you where you can find
gasoline along the way uh which hotels
uh you might want to stay at overnight
and oh by the way just in case you have
to
how to repair a flat tire particularly
if it's a Michelin tire because it's a
Pneumatic and you know what it's quite
easy to repair
and guess what that put Michelin on the
map why they weren't trying to sell you
more tires
they weren't telling you about the
features and benefits of round
or tire repair I mean that was in there
but it was only a how-to article not
necessarily a feature and benefit
what they were doing was they were
speaking to Their audience about what
Their audience was truly passionate
about which in Paris in 1900. was food
and by creating content
we got the audience to get into their
new Innovative automobile
and drive all the way out there into the
provinces for that absolutely remarkable
three-star restaurant
people got more Flats people had to
replace their tires but it was worth it
and oh by the way
Michelin sold more tires
so that that's a great story every time
you sort of
you know hit a pause and like well we're
doing content marketing and we need to
come up with a concept
back to the Michelin guide it's it's
great Foundation
let's go
to a modern definition where are we now
in the 21st century
when it comes to content marketing
well you can read the slide here and
read the definition and some people like
reading definitions I'm not going to
read it to you but I am going to
highlight a couple of words in the
definition that I think are absolutely
critical to any definition
of content marketing
the content that you create needs to be
relevant
and it also has to be valuable
now if it's not relevant then you're not
actually meeting my needs or interests
you know and why would I be interested
in them and we've gotten way too tired
I'm screening out the commercial that
comes on
um you know trying to sell out snow
tires and pardon me we live in Florida I
don't use the tires what the what the
heck is this commercial doing
you know interrupting what I'm watching
so relevance is important
relevance means that this content isn't
going to get screened out
and the valuable the valuable can can
work in a lot of different ways it can
be interesting
it can be useful
you know value is an interesting
proposition all by itself
but that's the key to content marketing
uh it's not just creating more spam
it's not just throwing more trash over
the fence and hoping something happens
this is something where if you've
created valuable and relevant content
you know what your customers will find
you that's a whole different kind of
proposition
I know there's some Skeptics they're
saying oh come on come on come on
content marketing is just a fancy new
name for social media marketing right
and the answer is well there is some
overlap and we're going to deal with
that in module three
but let me just be clear here
social media content is part of what
content marketing needs to create
but it can also create content for your
website and that's not the social media
it can also create content that your PR
people can share with
reporters or bloggers and that's not
normally considered social media content
and by the way all of that content can
be optimized so maybe it actually is
part of SEO not social media marketing
in fact that's the other place that
content marketing really overlaps
and it's not coincidental
it so happens that around February
2011 when Google rolled out the first of
its multiple versions of the panda
update
all of a sudden even seos started to pay
attention to content marketing why
because Google changed the rules and
what Google basically said is if your
content isn't valuable or relevant
you know what it's not going to rank
very well in our search angle for them
and all of a sudden people who had been
used to like putting keywords in the
right places
realized content matters I mean I've got
to actually tell stories that are
interesting I've got to create
information that's valuable uh
yeah you can make it relevant that's the
optimization part
but you know if you're trying to
optimize a piece of boring irrelevant
trash
God bless you good luck
so yeah content marketing
has grown it's like tripled in terms of
web search interest since the panda
update and then we're talking about
panda one of course there was Panda 2
Panda 3 Panda 4. I mean come on
Google is driving us in this direction
and so content marketing is pretty
relevant today
now one of the other things that people
in content marketing struggle with is oh
but you don't understand I do B2B
content marketing or I'm a small
business or pardon me I'm an Enterprise
and so content marketing has to come in
flavors right
well possibly maybe on occasion
so let's just question that assumption
for a second
you know content marketing has been
around now long enough and enough people
have done it but some research has been
conducted
and has been conducted against b2c
marketers and B2B marketers and small
business marketers and Enterprise level
marketers
and when they start asking key questions
like okay
we're going to try to determine what is
the difference between an effective
content marketer and an ineffective
content marketer
let's see the results
well first of all
the most important thing to Be an
Effective b2c content marketer
is you need a documented content
strategy
oh okay all right I mean people who are
winging it aren't as effective as people
who actually have thought about this and
written it down got it okay
no great Insight but you know
interesting to note
secondly they've got to have somebody in
charge who oversees content marketing oh
Lord does that mean we have to have a
reorg or maybe we just have to designate
somebody who reports to somebody else
whatever but guess what it really helps
if somebody is driving this process
third they've got to be using more
content marketing tactics than their
less effective peers
and this is not an argument more is
better this is just pardon me that's the
way the data falls out the people who
are actually more effective are doing
more different kinds of things
a broader range of tactics
and who knows maybe it's that broader
range that's part of the success formula
same thing is true with social media
platforms
the effective content marketers are
using more than the ineffective ones
and last but not least and this may be a
sort of a result of the first four
by gosh effective content marketers
generally have greater percentage
of the overall marketing budget in their
organization
wow okay
that's the b2c marketing for me but you
don't understand I I'm not a b2c
marketer okay
so let's take a look at the B2B content
marketing formula
guess what
you need to have a documented content
marketing strategy to Be an Effective
B2B content marketer you need to have
someone who oversees content marketing
strategy it helps if you are using more
tactics
and more social media platforms and
guess what you spend a higher percentage
of your overall marketing budget
on content marketing well that's similar
to the b2c content markers but you
understand B2B is different yeah there's
a couple small differences but guess
what overall the top five criteria
are similar
and when you get the small business
here's what you're going to see
same five criteria
and you're in an Enterprise I know the
world is different for Enterprises
actually not so much
so four different data points let's net
it out there's a pattern
and the pattern is I don't care what
flavor of content marketer you are you
can be b2c B2B you can be small business
you can be large Enterprise at the end
of the day there are five things that
you've got to focus on
if you want to be effective
we've already covered these and are
there differences between small
businesses and large Enterprises between
B2B and b2c well sure
but they're all at the margin
what's the downside if we don't do this
you know is anyone going to come in and
like wakas and the answer is
um maybe not inside your boardroom
but it may happen on the next sales call
that one of your sales people makes they
may encounter someone I like to call the
man in the chair
and the men in the chair actually refers
back to a classic McGraw-Hill ad
campaign from I think the 1960s
but basically the guy in the chair asks
theoretically some questions from quote
maybe your sales person okay I don't
know anything about you I don't know
about your company I don't know about
your company's product I don't know
about your company's you know reputation
or anything about you and so what was it
you were going to try to sell me
and that's the downside of not having a
Content marketing program
content marketing has been around for
over 100 years
but in the online world
customers are behaving in lots of new
ways and they're consuming content on
various kinds and types of devices
that changes things content marketing is
now about creating content that
consumers will engage with and act upon
not just read or listen to or watch
so in this introductory module we're
going to provide you with an
understanding of how content marketing
affects the decision-making process when
people are on the customer journey to
making a purchase and with a solid
content marketing strategy your
customers buying decisions
can actually happen faster you can
basically
shorten the decision-making process
and you can reach and expand to new
prospects so one of the things that we
hope that you're going to learn after
basically taking this module you should
be able to do the following first of all
you can Define content marketing and
other related Concepts secondly you
should be able to explain why content
needs to be relevant and valuable in
order for it to be effective third you
need to describe the overlap between
content marketing SEO social media
marketing
fourth you need to name five traits of
effective content marketers
and last but not least you need to
explain the benefits of content
marketing these are our objectives and
hopefully they're going to be your
learning outcomes
so content marketing Is Not A New
Concept it's been around for over a
hundred years in fact one of the classic
Foundation stories of you know the birth
of content marketing goes all the way
back to the Michelin Brothers in France
and the Michelin Brothers you know in
case you haven't done your history
that's okay you know low refresher right
now
we're two brothers who made pneumatic
tires and they were trying to sell them
along with an Innovative product at its
time called the automobile
in an era where the roads were horrible
in a place France where frankly people
didn't like to get outside of Paris and
into the provinces because my God what
was worth going out there for you know
or Paris it's all Happening Here
and what the Michelin Brothers realized
is if they wanted to sell more tires
they had to get people to drive farther
and farther
and use them
so what did they come up with
the concept that really is the birth of
content Marketing in my book
was the Michelin guide
and the Michelin guide was unique in
that it reviewed restaurants not just
restaurants nearby in Paris but
restaurants out there in the provinces
and the Michelin brothers are the ones
who came up with the one two and three
star rating system to say this
restaurant I know it's way out there
it's you know bad roads but guess what
to die for the Ratatouille oh you you
gotta have it this is a three-star
restaurant you you it's worth making the
trip
and oh by the way and since we're going
to give you a guide and you have to get
out of Paris in order to get there we're
going to tell you where you can find
gasoline along the way which hotels you
might want to stay at overnight and oh
by the way just in case you have to
how to repair a flat tire particularly
if it's a Michelin tire because it's a
Pneumatic and you know what it's quite
easy to repair
and guess what that put Michelin on the
map why they weren't trying to sell you
more tires
they weren't telling you about the
features and benefits of round
or tire repair I mean that was in there
but it was only a how-to article not
necessarily a feature and benefit
what they were doing was they were
speaking to Their audience about what
Their audience was truly passionate
about which in Paris in 1900
was food
and by creating content
that got the audience to get into their
new Innovative automobile
and drive all the way out there into the
provinces for that absolutely remarkable
three-star restaurant
people got more Flats people had to
replace their tires but it was worth it
and oh by the way
Michelin sold more tires
so that
that's a great story every time you sort
of
you know and this is Rob Sanders from
Simply learn and today we're going to
talk about affiliate marketing so let's
jump right into it and take a look
inside an office environment right now
we have Chuck here Chuck's doing a
little bit of pacing John walks in the
office hey man what's with all the
pacing everything all right Chuck
responded hey I'm just worried that I
might have exhausted every way we can
advertise our product I mean I've done
SEO I've done paid search I've done
email I've done social man nothing's
working I gotta come up with something
new ASAP well John responds hey don't
worry I think I've got your solution for
you man hang tight relax take a load off
here's my solution affiliate marketing
first off before you ask the question
what's affiliate marketing let's talk
about why we need affiliate marketing so
let's dig into affiliate marketing so
John's just taking over now and he's
gonna let Chuck know everything there is
to know about affiliate marketing so the
first question John answers for Chuck
what is affiliate marketing so affiliate
marketing is a form of digital marketing
that involves a merchant it involves a
merchant paying commissions to a website
or other entities so if I'm selling a
product basically somebody else sells
that product for me I'm gonna pay that
person a commission for selling my
product it's that simple that's what
affiliate marketing is okay so basically
what these margins are doing or other
entities they're advertising your
product so they're advertising your
product with a referral so they're
passing on their own customers to you so
that they can buy your product and again
the exchanges you give that website or
other entity a commission that's more or
less what affiliate marketing is so
John's gonna have us take a look at each
of these components of affiliate
marketing in detail take it away John so
John says first we have the merchant AKA
The Brand the seller the Creator the
founder the owner the inspiration the
innovator hey this is the person who
came up with this brilliant idea This
brilliant idea has to get out there
we're the merchant we're trying to get
this brilliant idea out to the masses so
this is the component of affiliate
marketing that creates the product the
merchant could be anyone okay so it
could be startups it's a large
multinational companies International
companies non-profits for-profits
individuals independent contractors
Freelancers a group of people who have a
passion for something okay it could be
anybody there's no limit the affiliate
aka the publisher so the affiliate is
basically that third party website or
entity which promotes the merchants
products and tries to convince potential
customers of the merchants products
value so this affiliate's going to
represent the merchant on their behalf
and try and get their clients to
basically purchase that particular
Merchant's product so the affiliate
could be incentivized based on you know
registrations email sign ups sales and
subscriptions so it doesn't always come
down to you know sales you know if I'm
just trying to get you know build my
email list then hey I can incentivize
that affiliate to push email signups if
I've got this big you know offline you
know promotion that I'm doing at this
particular mall and I want to get people
there well I can get an affiliate and
incentivize that affiliate to drive and
help me drive registrations for this
event so it doesn't always have to be
sales per se so in effect you the
merchant and the affiliate work out some
type of commission deal based on what
you're incentivizing so the relationship
between the affiliate and the merchant
is made possible with the help help of
an affiliate Network so that's the third
component here we need somebody to bring
the two together that Merchant who has
This brilliant idea and the affiliate
who has potential customers that could
potentially Drive registrations sales
sign ups Etc to the merchant so the
affiliate network is the one who brings
the two together so the affiliate
Network in effect acts as the middleman
the person in between the merchants and
Affiliates it allows Merchants to find
and collaborate with not just any
affiliate but the affiliate best suited
for their particular brand and product
because you want to find somebody who is
going to be passionate who's relevant
who has your prospective customers in
mind because they're the ones that are
going to help those protective customers
purchase your product so that's what the
affiliate network does it helps bring
the merchants and Affiliates together so
that the affiliate can help advertise
and sell on behalf of the merchant so
with the affiliate Network Merchants can
use tools for tracking and Reporting and
processing payments for Affiliates so
really that affiliate network is the
glue that holds it all together they're
not just one to introduce a merchant and
affiliate they offer it all so as a
merchant you want to be able to manage
your Affiliates so you're not going to
have one affiliate you're going to have
multiple Affiliates so you want to be
able to use the appropriate tools
available to you in the affiliate
Network to see and track how sales are
going and when sales happen okay or
commissions happen you want to be able
to use that affiliate Network to
compensate that affiliate appropriately
and then finally the customer customer
aka the consumer is the most important
component of all of this take it away
John so the consumer is the final and
most important component without
customers to buy products the merchant
would not have any revenue and the
Philly it would not get any commission
so we need customers so if you are
looking to become a digital marketing
expert then here we have post graduate
program in digital marketing so are you
ready to boost your career in digital
marketing accelerate your career and
gain the skills you need to thrive in
the industry ready to get started click
the link in the description box and
embark on your journey to professional
growth and achievement hurry up spots
are filling up fast this is Rob Sanders
from Simply learn and today we're going
to talk about keyword research so what
are we going to talk about when we talk
about keyword research we're going to
talk about why we would do keyword
research for SEO we're going to talk
about the types of keywords that we need
to research we're going to talk about
some methodologies best practices on how
to do keyword research some alternate
suggestions we're going to talk about
keyword clustering and then we're going
to talk about some tools that you can
use to do your keyword research so let's
start with the why we would do keyword
research so Jesse is planning to publish
a Blog of pizza recipes so she was doing
pizza recipes step by step piece of
recipes with sausage homemade pizza
toppings pizza dough recipes thin crust
pizzas she's doing a lot of different
topics on pizza recipes well what Jesse
needs to do is understand what's going
to drive traffic to these blog posts if
she's writing about you know different
topics around pizza recipes so she's
Unsure how these blogs are going to
drive traffic so she really needs to
understand that hey you need to choose
the right keywords to drive traffic so
the question is if you're writing a blog
post about recipes with sausages is
pizza recipes with sausages or recipes
for free the best keyword to use maybe
maybe not so you need to take uh care
and shoes in the key you words to align
with your content so that's really the
idea of why we would do keyword research
because some of the issues with keywords
that are poorly chosen are they can have
low search volume for example you may
choose a keyword that just a lot of
people aren't using to search for or
they can be highly competitive so if you
choose a keyword that's very broad or
popular it can be very competitive and
take you a long time to be found for
that keyword or you could just make the
mistake of choosing a keyword that is in
aligned with your content or you can
choose keywords but use them incorrectly
with your content so these are some of
the issues that you can encounter if you
just go about choosing keywords randomly
without due diligence without the proper
research so low search volume will lead
to less traffic High competition you may
not even rank at all okay if somebody
finds you for a keyword that's not
relevant to the topic they're just going
to leave the page and if you're not you
using the right keywords and or if you
are using the right keywords and not
using them correctly in the content then
your pages may not even be found in
organic search so you really have to
take care and choosing the keywords to
me that's the most important step with
SEO is keyword research so we're going
to talk about the types of keyword
research then so we have short tail
keywords and we have long tail keywords
so if you write a blog post about pizza
recipes well what are you going to
choose a short tail or long tail so
let's talk about short tail keywords
first so short tail keywords are
keywords that are usually three keywords
in a phrase or shorter in some cases it
may be two keywords in a phrase or
shorter so short tip keywords usually
have high search volume which means
likely means higher competition but what
it also means it could be lower
conversions because short sale keywords
like for example pizza recipes could be
considered a short show keyword but
maybe somebody's looking for homemade
pizza recipes or pizza recipes from
their favorite Italian restaurant so
short taking words may not be as
relevant so if we compare it with long
tail keywords chances are you're going
to have lower competition that's one of
the benefits but you're also going to
have lower search volume but with longer
tail keywords the key word is probably
going to be more relevant with the
content you're writing about so
therefore the conversion rates likely
going to be higher so that's really the
difference between short-term keywords
and long tail keywords if you want to
look at simplistically short tail
keywords are Broad in nature it's going
to capture a lot of eyeballs but those
eyeballs may look at your content is not
relevant versus long tail keywords that
may be very relevant but not as many
eyeballs on them so short tail keywords
the characteristics they're not as
specific usually they're less than three
words they have high search volume and
high competition so if you just choose
pizza recipes could take you a while to
rank for that keyword but when you rank
you're going to get the traffic but
again it may not convert because the key
word is Broad in nature so pizza recipes
is a short tail keyword that may not be
exactly what you're writing about in
your blog post so it may draw a lot of
traffic but the traffic may not do
anything so the longer tail keywords are
very specific they consist of more than
three words in the search query they
have relatively low search volume
competition so the chance of you ranking
higher faster for that long take a word
is probably going to be greater because
not many other websites are trying to
rank for that same keyword and so the
benefit of that is if you have let's
just say homemade pizza recipes with
mushrooms that's a long tail key word
but if somebody's looking for that type
of pizza recipe then you know you're
going to track the right traffic and
chances are that traffic's going to
engage or convert based on the type of
conversion you have in place so example
would be the homemade pizza dough
recipes that'd be another example more
than thick keywords in the phrase very
specific we're talking about homemade
pizza dough recipe so we're not talking
about just pizza recipes so it's a
little bit more specific in nature
longer too so these keywords are used
for targeted Pages including blog posts
if you're writing a blog post
specifically about pizza recipes with
homemade dough then this is the key word
you likely would want to use versus just
pizza recipes so let's look at an
example between a short tail keyword and
a long tail keyword and to accentuate
the differences we're going to use
Google's Keyword Planner tool so
Google's keyboard Planner tool is
located in Google ads the Google ads
platform and when you're in the Google
ads platform you can simply click on
tools and then Keyword Planner and so
what Keyword Planner allows us to do is
get a sense of the type of volume that a
particular keyword has so what goes
Google's Keyword Planner does is they
show you the average monthly searches
this is the average monthly search
volume of a key word over the past 12
months and so in this example we're
going to choose pizza recipes and
homemade pizza dough recipes so one
short tail and one long tail so we enter
those keywords in we're going to click
get results and what Google's going to
do is it's going to show us the volume
of those keywords so for pizza recipe we
could see the average monthly search
volume is 33 100 for pizza recipe so
note that pizza recipe and pizza recipes
are closely related keywords and so what
Google does is they consider that a
close variance so meaning if somebody
ties a piece of recipe then they're also
in Google's eyes looking for pizza
recipes so it's a close variance and so
for the keyword pizza recipe which is
short tail we could see on average over
the past 12 months this keyword received
33 100 queries and so if we hover over
the graph we could see basically the
volume the average volume per month so
here I could see for this particular
keyword here the volume per month is 33
to 1000 and then I can see the actual
volume over the past 12 months and then
for the long tail keyword I can see
homemade pizza dough recipe again close
variants homemade pizza dough recipes I
can see over the past 12 months with the
search volume is for this on average
it's 2400 but I could see here in
December the volume went up to 3600 but
for example in May it was 1900. so it's
gonna fluctuate a bit over the past 12
months but on average it's about 2400.
so shorter tail a lot of more volume
longer tail not as much volume but
nonetheless there is volume here and so
these are the differences between a
short tail and a longer tail and said
well Google's Keyword Planner also does
is allow us to get a sense of what the
competition is and so here I can see the
competition is low for both of these
keywords fair enough so we now know that
if we want to optimize or choose the
keyword homemade pizza dough recipe for
our blog post we know for ranked on page
one of Google even in the top spot we
can expect about 2400 search queries for
that keyword now whether you get all
2400 clicks for that keyword remains to
be seen chances are you're not going to
get all 2400 you're going to get a
Lion's Share of those clicks but you're
going to at least get some volume on it
so even the longer tick keywords have a
lot of Promise because there is some
search volume here for this keyword how
to do a proper keyword research so we
looked at Google's Keyword Planner tool
and Google ads and we typed in two
keywords and we were able to get a sense
of what the average volume is so we
definitely want to choose key words
based on the following factors we want
to choose it based on search volume
search volume is a good indicator of the
potential traffic we can obtain so again
for the keyword homemade pizza dough
recipe we know that it averages 2400 a
month in search volume again we may not
get all 2400 but we're going to get a
line share of that we also need to look
at competition and so Google's Keyword
Planner gives us a high medium or low in
terms of the competition but if you're
somebody who wants to get a better sense
of what the competition is and you
should because competition is a key
component in choosing keywords and so
what I want to do is get a sense of how
many people are actually optimizing for
that keyword so Google's Keyword Planner
tool is going to give me a low medium
high really what I want to do is get a
better sense of that numerically so what
I can do is go into Google will search
and I could type in pizza recipes and I
could see there's about 1 billion
results that's a lot of results however
that means that every potential web page
out there on the internet that mentions
pizza recipes is going to be included in
this number here and so I want to get a
better sense of who's optimizing for
pizza recipes so I'm going to put in the
all in title syntax and so what that is
going to ask Google to do is tell me all
the websites that have pizza recipes the
keyword pizza recipes in the title tag
so if I do all entitled colon space then
pizza recipes my result drops down to
336 000. so what that tells me is that
there are 336
000 results with the keyword pizza
recipes in the title tag now if I want
to focus in on my other keyword if I
choose my other keyword was a longer
tail keyword homemade pizza dough recipe
so if I type that keyword in the
homemade pizza dough recipe or recipes
remember close variants and I just click
enter or type the keyword in hit my
Enter key I'm going to get 35 Million
results but again is that really an
indicator of the type of competition I
have no because every listing that
mentions homemade pizza dough recipes is
going to be included in the search
results so I'm going to type in my all
in title colon space and then I'm going
to get a better sense of how many
websites have the keyword homemade pizza
dough recipes in the title tag and I get
2 160 different results so here I can
see the first result in the title tag
homemade pizza dough recipe second one
homemade pizza dough recipe so these are
sites web pages that have that keyword
in the title tag so now I have a
numerical number to work with and so the
thing you have to understand about SEO
specifically about keyword research is
you need to do research on a few
different keywords not just one or two
so what we want to do is have a
spreadsheet the spreadsheet is going to
contain keywords that we can potentially
want to optimize for choose as keywords
to optimize for SEO and so my
recommendation is you come up with a
theme first so the theme for us in this
exercise is pizza recipes and so that's
our theme so we chose the keyword pizza
recipes so the close variance here is
pizza recipe what was the volume well we
know the volume was 33 100 for pizza
recipe so what are we going to do we're
going to put that number in in our
volume column what was the competition
well if we go back and type in pizza
recipes it was 683 000 so I'm going to
type in 683
000. what was our next keyword well it
was pizza or homemade pizza dough
recipes so if I go go back for this
particular keyword is 2400 so I'm going
to put 2400 in under my volume column
and then what was my competition well my
competition was I typed that keyword
back in
2160. so I'm going to put 2
160. so now I have an idea of what kind
of volume and what kind of competition I
have now you want to do this for a
number of different keywords and when
you do it for a number of keywords what
you do want to do is obviously choose a
relevant keyword that has high volume
and low competition so another way of
saying it is the volume or ratio of
volume to competition and so basically
what we could do is take volume divided
by competition if I make that a
percentage I can see it's 0.35 percent
is the ratio between volume of
competition if I do the same for my
longer tail keyword 2400 divided by 2160
I can see that 111 so this just kind of
proves the point that yeah I'm still
going to get some volume but I have a
better chance of ranking for this longer
tlk word homemade pizza dough recipes so
you want to be able to do that for a
number of keywords and examine the
volume the competition and the ratio
between volume and competition for your
themed keywords in this case pizza
recipes so relevancy you want to choose
keywords that are very relevant to the
content that you're writing and then
again commercial intent what keywords
are going to drive more conversions and
revenue for the business so when we talk
about commercial intent we're talking
about you know are you choosing keywords
that are going to get somebody to do
what you want them to do so we could say
You Know download pizza dough recipes so
somebody's typing in the keyword
download pizza dough recipes then
chances are they're going to find you
come to your site and take action by
downloading that pizza dough recipe so
you want to be able to also think about
the intent of the keyword is it going to
help you drive conversions and revenue
if you're an e-commerce site so search
volume is the average monthly search
volume made for a particular keyword and
phrase so we can get that number using
Google's Keyword Planner tool in the
Google ads platform we want to Target
keywords with high search volume that
will help bring traffic to the website
we want volume but we want to take into
account seasonality as well so that's
where the Google's Keyword Planner tool
comes in place because if we go back
again we can just hover over we can get
a sense of any particular Trend going on
or seasonality so for example if I saw
large growth in the winter months and
not much volume growth in the summer
months than that might indicate to me
that this keyword is more popular during
the winter time so pay attention to the
graphs that you know the Keyword Planner
tool gives you use them to your
advantage to take into account
seasonality so a good example would be
fun funny Halloween costumes well we
know that for Halloween you're going to
have a spike probably towards the end of
September all the way through October
and then it's going to drop after
October 31st which is Halloween so
that's an example but in the case of
pizza recipes you know you may find that
more people are choosing to search for
pizza recipes during maybe the summer
months versus the winter months so pay
attention to seasonality it will affect
search volume so competition based on
our example it's one of the most
important key metrics you don't want to
choose a key word that's highly
competitive because if it's competitive
then it's going to be harder to rank
number one or even on page one of Google
depending on competitive it is so high
search volume low competition in other
words the ratio between the two is the
ideal combination so going back to the
spreadsheet recommend you have that
spreadsheet handy put your theme in
place okay theme and pizza recipes we
use Google's Keyword Planner tool to
find the volume we use the all entitled
syntax to find the competition so we
entered both of those numbers in and we
get our ratio and so when you have these
numbers for a number of different
keywords you want to be able to choose
that ratio of high volume low
competition but always relevancy always
trumps ratio so always go with a key
word that is going to be relevant to
your content don't choose a keyword
that's not relevant if you choose a
keyword that's not relevant it's not
going to bode well for user engagement
so the difficulty of a keyword ranges
from 0 to 100 and Google's keyword tool
so it's going to be easy it's going to
be medium it's going to be hard but my
recommendation is also to get the
numerical factor and that's the all in
title syntax and again relevancy is what
drives the traffic to your website and
keep the traffic there on your website
and also not only will it keep the
traffic on your website but hopefully
get that traffic to engage and convert
so that's the key about relevancy you
always want to choose keywords that are
relevant to your content even if it's
sacrificing volume relevancy again
trumps volume and competition so always
choose relevant keywords first so when
you do that you're always almost
guaranteeing that at some point
somebody's going to find your content
because somebody out there might be
looking for it and if they do you're
going to get found and then the
engagement is going to be better so
understand your business find keywords
that are relevant to your business and
then focus on those keywords that'll
help you with getting the right traffic
to your site always keep in mind the
commercial intent so these keywords are
more specific and result in conversion
rate for example buying is a good
commercial intent keyword so if you
really want somebody to come to your
website and buy then focus on those
types of keywords in the case of the
pizza recipes maybe it's download could
be our commercial intent keyword again
there may be low search volume but those
are the type of keywords you want to
focus on because that's the type of
traffic you want to drive to your site
so some other examples a commercial
intent keywords or discount deal your
coupon shipping you know don't be afraid
to use some of these keywords as part of
your longer till keyword phrase again
the volume may not be high but the
traffic quality is probably going to be
better so keyword research is the
foundation for SEO so if you have chosen
your keywords properly then if you do
get ranked for those keywords then it's
going to lead to better engagement with
some conversions and so when we talk
about keywords we also want to talk
about our primary and secondary keyword
so every page should have at least a
primary keyword and then a second carry
keyword to work with so primary keywords
are really defining the nature of your
con content the secondary keywords are
relevant to the primary keyword so why
do we choose a primary and secondary
keyword because you may choose a keyword
as a primary keyword that is relevant to
the content but may not necessarily rank
very high or have a lot of volume that
secondary keyword is also relevant to
the primary keyword but also relevant to
content and you may rank for that
secondary keyword so you always want to
go with two keywords versus just one
keyword you want to give your yourself a
chance to rank for at least two
different types of keywords of relevant
nature so for web page there can be
several secondary keywords but only one
primary keyword so your primary keyword
is always going to be relevant to your
content secondary keywords can be
relevant to the keyword but and you may
have multiple secondary keywords but
it's also going to be related to the
content and it gives you a better
opportunity to be found between both the
primary and secondary in search Okay so
let's take a look at another example of
how to use primary keywords and
secondary keywords when choosing
keywords so for primary keyword is
healthy diet plan remember healthy diet
plan is directly related to the content
so that's what we're talking about but
these secondary keywords are also
related to content and play off the
primary keyword and so what we want to
do is go to cool Google's Keyword
Planner tool and get an idea of the
volume for healthy diet plan and then
also the volume and competition for some
of these secondary keywords like healthy
diet for weight loss healthy diet food
low carb diet healthy meal plans and
diet plan weight loss so if I go in to
Google's Keyword Planner and type those
keywords in I'm going to choose get
results and now here I could see healthy
diet plan keyword I'm focusing on is my
primary keyword has an average monthly
search volume of 9900 and then some of
my secondary keywords healthy diet foods
diet plan way weight loss low carb diet
you know Google will give me a number of
different keywords to work with so I'm
going to look at the search volume of
that as well and so ideally what I want
to do is be able to then look at the
volume and then look at the competition
so healthy diet plan to go into my
keyword analysis here that's my theme so
that's my keyword what's my volume for
healthy diet plan nine thousand nine
hundred what's my competition so my
competition is seventy four thousand
seven hundred and that's going to give
me a ratio of volume to competition of
13 so that's my content's about that's a
considered a short tail keyword because
it has a lot of competition and so my
ratio is 13 and what I want to do is I
want to be able to put these other
secondary keywords in here as well maybe
even go to a little longer tail because
I want to be able to find two key
release two keywords I want to be able
to find my primary keyword that's
relevant to my content and then I want
to be able to find my secondary keyword
which is again related to the primary
keyword which is also related to the
content and so I want to be able to
choose two keywords basically and I want
to choose two keywords that are relevant
that have good ratio between volume and
competition so that's the whole idea
again I'm how to do keyword research you
want to be able to find your keywords
use the tools available to you and get a
sense of what the volume is what the
competition is look at the ratio between
the volume and competition and then
based on the content choose that primary
keyword and then again based on the
keyword you chose choose some secondary
keywords as well because you want to be
found for not just one keyword but
multiple keywords okay let's look at
some alternative suggestions to keyword
research so for doing keyword research
we want to take into account LSI
keywords we could take into account
other platforms that that host a lot of
content like quora or Reddit we can use
Google suggestions in the keyword search
bar we can use popular platforms like
Wikipedia and we can use social media
bookmarking like Reddit so there are
lots of suggestions that we can obtain
from various sources so let's start with
LSI keywords and LSI stands for latent
semantic insect indexing and so
basically what it is it's just keywords
that are linked to your primary keyword
and so when you're choosing keywords you
always want to choose that primary
keyword and then secondary keywords that
are similar to the primary keyword and
usually those are LSI or latent semantic
indexing type keywords so they're used
to drive relevant traffic to your page
so if you focus in on one keyword we
want to have other keywords that are
similar to increase our visibility on
the search engine result pages so we
could find latent semantic indexing
right in search so so if we use the term
healthy diet if we go to Google search
for example if I type in healthy diet in
Google search all I need to do is scroll
to the bottom of the page and I can see
searches related to healthy diet so
healthy diet menu healthy diet essay
what does a healthy diet look like
notice at the top Google's also given me
some other suggestions here so they're
saying low-fat diet veganism gluten-free
diet so there's lots of different
suggestions right in Google search bar
so all of these are LSI related keywords
so if you're optimizing a page for a
healthy diet then you could choose
low-fat diet as a secondary keyword you
can use gluten-free diet as a secondary
keyword it really depends on what the
content is but you always want to
support your content with as much LSI
keywords as possible so you can be found
for as many different keywords as
possible in Google search so it's
important because if you have a Blog
that that you know talks about python so
how do the search engines know if the
website python is about the programming
language or the snake so Google for
example uses LSI keywords to understand
what the page is specifically focusing
on so if you're just focusing on Python
and your content you want to support
that with LSI keywords and so that will
allow your web page to better
communicate with Google also to have the
visibility to show up on search so they
can certainly improve your search
positioning and featured Snippets as
well so if you have a keyword that
answers a question you can certainly
found for feature snippet for example
maybe you know healthy diet recipes if I
type that in you can see here there's a
featured snippet so if I'm talking about
recipes that's a key word I may want to
use and if I use that then Google has an
opportunity to see what my content's
about and place my information at the
top in this featured snippet you can
also again see what some of the
questions are being asked what males are
good for weight loss what is a good
healthy diet plan all of these could be
keyword phrases that you can use so the
answers are right here in Google so core
is a great platform because core is a
platform that people go and ask
questions in a community responds with
answers or responses to that particular
question or topic and so the great thing
about core is it's a good eye it's a
good place for you to go to get some
ideas about a specific topic so if we're
talking about healthy dieting so we can
find keywords with high search volume
writing quora so the whole idea is you
can look at you know the top five
questions for specific topic like
healthy dieting and find relevant
keywords to healthy dieting so if you
just type in that particular keyword in
quora you're gonna probably get some
responses to questions or responses to
somebody else's question and so if we we
take a look at core for example so if I
just type in healthy dieting what I'm
going to do is I'm going to get some
responses to the the topic healthy
dieting so what's the best diet for
Healthy Living what are the top five
tips for a healthy diet habit so all of
these could be keyword phrases that you
could take away with for your own
content and so the benefit here is
you're getting kind of an idea of what's
trending what people are talking about
and if you use tips for a healthy diet
habit for example and you optimize for
that well again that could turn around
and bode well for you because you could
be featured in Google as a featured
snippet at the top here you can also
turn around and use LSI related keywords
for healthy diet habits and you can
simply just look for those LSI keywords
right in Google remember at the bottom
or at the Top If you scroll down I could
see some related LSI keywords at the
bottom so writing Google as well you
could see in the Google search bar that
Google provides some LSI related
keywords to your query so if I go back
here and type in healthy diet recipes I
can see here Google's suggesting some
other related keywords healthy diet menu
healthy diet for man healthy diet foods
healthy diet for women so these are all
LSI related keywords that you can use to
support your primary keyword and the
content you're writing about so we've
talked about LSI keywords where to find
them so they're found right here they
can be found at the top of Google and
they can be found at the bottom you can
also then go to core as well and get
some ideas for the types of questions
they're being asked so if you ask a
question and use that as your keyword
phrase then again you have an
opportunity of showing up for a featured
snippet in Google just by doing some
additional research within Google itself
or on Quorum so according to Google the
autocomplete predictions are
automatically generated by Google's
algorithm without any human intervention
it's based on a number of factors but
the primary factor is how often past
users have searched for terms so Google
collects all the keyword queries that
somebody types in and they're suggesting
some of the most popular terms that
people have typed in so if I go back to
Google again if I start typing recipes I
could see some of the other queries that
somebody else has typed in or some of
the most popular queries related to that
topic so if you enter the keyword
healthy diet Google's going to suggest
multiple keyword suggestions that users
have asked in the past and you could
certainly get the search volume of those
keywords just by looking in Google
itself I can see for healthy diet
recipes billions of pages related to
healthy diet recipes I can also get the
search volume by going into Google's
Keyword Planner so if I type in healthy
diet I'm going to be able to see what my
search volume is for that keyword and in
addition I can see the seasonality of
that particular keyword and in addition
to that Google is going to provide some
other related keywords to my search
query so if I'm looking for healthy diet
Google is going to suggest hey maybe you
should choose healthy food or healthy
eating or how to lose weight so those
are LSI related keywords that Google
provides in the keyword plan which is
built into the Google ads platform
another option for you is Wikipedia so
Wikipedia is a vast platform of content
so we could turn Wikipedia into our own
assets and use it to our own Advantage
by finding relevant keywords in an easy
fashion so with Wikipedia we can
identify a list of keywords in The Meta
description itself we could choose
keywords from the paragraph of Wikipedia
that has many relevant keywords or we
could take a look at keywords from the
Wikipedia content section so we can also
see additional Pages like the see also
section that gives relevant keywords
that you're looking for we can also look
at the references section as they
contain relevant keywords so go to
Wikipedia as an example and I type in
healthy diet into Wikipedia here I can
get just in the first paragraph alone I
can see some additional keywords that I
might choose to use like micronutrients
I never knew that micronutrients was
related to healthy diet but Wikipedia is
providing some information about what
micronutrients is and maybe I can use
that as a keyword an LSI related keyword
to my content so if I scroll down I get
to see also section so it might give me
some information food information
consumers for example dietary guidelines
I can look at categories like dietetics
and diets I can also look at the
references section so I can also see
what information was provided like
health effects of overweight and obesity
I can look at diet and physical activity
so all of these are related to my main
keyword healthy diet so the answers are
right in here on the platform they're
just all over the page so Wikipedia has
an abundance of information you just
need to know where to look so again with
Wikipedia you can look no further in the
first paragraph you look no further than
the see also section the references
section category section there's lots of
information right on the page itself to
help you get ideas for keywords so if
you Google your keyword with Wikipedia
term in the search query and get
relevant keywords from the title tags in
the search so you can also do that as
well so if I type in healthy diet
Wikipedia and search I can also get some
information here as well so people also
search for healthy food advantages or
healthy food habits essay or information
about healthy food all of these are
related to my keyword healthy diet so
again another bit of information for you
to choose or look to choose some
additional keywords for so Reddit it's a
popular Community where where people
post content and discuss a variety of
topics so that's what Reddit is so with
the help of subreddits an individual can
find relevant keywords with with high
search volume so in Reddit there's an
easy way to find out keywords they have
a keyword tool called keyword it so the
keyword it gives the average monthly
searches for a particular keyword so if
we type a Word in key Reddit and choose
keywords from the auto generator list
this tool will extract the keywords and
give us those relevant terms with search
volumes so if we go to the keyword it
and Show an example of that for example
healthy food if I get keywords I can see
what keywords are relevant in the search
volume of that keyword so if I just type
in healthy food keyword tool is going to
tell me some relevant keywords and what
the volume is so if you don't have the
Keyword Planner tool in Google ads
available to you this is a good
alternative solution to finding keywords
so it's free you just need to go to
keyword.com type in your keyword click
get keywords and what it's going to do
is give you some relevant keywords
related to your primary keyword with the
search volume let's talk about keyword
clustering now so the whole idea about
keyword clustering is to really take
advantage of the keywords that we're
optimizing for to gain higher ranking so
if we can cluster keywords together in a
theme and that theme of keywords is
relevant to a specific page of a website
then we have a better opportunity to
rank so in other words why do we have to
Target just one keyword when we can
Target many so keep in mind you know LSI
keywords we want to group a bunch of
keywords together that are similar for
Content so for example after some
keyword research you can thematically
group keywords into a core topic so for
example we can cluster these group of
keywords together like for example what
is SEO how does that SEO work intro to
SEO what are the basics of SEO all of
those are related to the chord theme
what is SEO another cluster of keywords
for example could be SEO techniques SEO
best practices tips and tricks website
optimization on-page SEO techniques Etc
so those are clusters of keywords okay
that we can group together in themes and
if we group keywords together in themes
we can apply that to a particular
content on our website so the whole idea
behind clustering keywords it's going to
provide more diversity more of an
opportunity for us to be found so that's
the whole idea behind clustering so some
additional steps remember stay up to
date on industry news to brainstorm your
ideas first and identify a list of
keywords like ethema keywords that you
can cluster together and then you could
determine the keywords that your
competitors are already ranking for so
for example if we we want to rank for
the keyword SEO best practices for
example we can use a tool called keyword
Moz if I go to keyword the keyword
Explorer tool of Moz and just type in
SEO best practices what it's going to do
is it's going to give me some volume
related to that particular keyword but
more importantly what it's also going to
do is going to show me what pages are
already ranked for that particular
keyword so therefore I can get a sense
of who is already ranking for that
keyword so here I can see Moz Moz
medium.com alexa.com so I can get a
sense of what web pages are ranked for a
particular keyword or group of keywords
I want to rank for myself
SEO is an important part of the
marketing strategy in case your website
doesn't show up on the first page of the
search engine then you need to work on
it to solve all your SEO related
problems we've come up with a solution
welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
and today we will be discussing the top
10 tips that every marketer needs to
know so let's get started and see the
first step
the first step is voice search now voice
search will impact search queries in
2021 according to dialogtech.com
in the United States of America 55
percent of the households will have
their own smart speaker by 2022.
well that's a lot so if you're planning
to optimize your voice search consider
choosing wise keywords
find out longer phrases that Searchers
use in daily life conversation
voice search is a more suitable way for
searching long and more natural sounding
phrases creating detailed and relevant
answers are essential when optimizing
for voice search so always remember to
create Persona based content
next create web pages that can answer
FAQ use
because when Searchers ask a question
they begin their question with words
like who when whom what however there
are many reasons for using voice search
such as dictating text messages looking
for a video on YouTube calling a person
from your contact list asking for
directions
Etc
according to Forbes voice search
drastically improves your user
experience due to its extensive use
search engines such as Google are
focusing on voice search optimization
Google's voice search shows websites on
top that load quickly in that case you
must always ensure that your website has
a responsive design its images are
optimized the files are compressed
implementation of website caching is
done properly to improve page speed and
finally the last important Point your
server's response time is reduced
now the second step in the process is
the mobile optimization
now you must already know how important
it is to make your site mobile friendly
for a better user experience but did you
also know that having a mobile friendly
application impacts your search engine
optimization
sem Rush confirms that by the year 2025
approximately 70 percent of Internet
users will access the internet through
mobile devices
Google's mobile friendly update has
resulted in a big change in search
rankings with the help of Google's free
mobile friendly test have a look at how
effective your mobile website is also
take a peek at the mobile usability
report in Google's search console
now let's talk about tip number three
that is Google's eight principles Google
has confirmed that content quality is an
essential factor for ranking on search
engine result pages
but what does quality mean to Google
well content that fulfills the Google
eat principle will rank higher each
stands for expertise
authoritativeness and trustworthiness
these elements will determine if a web
page has a useful quality content
Google uses the combination of
algorithms to deliver the best results
for users Google Panda is one of the
famous algorithms of Google which
emphasizes delivering high quality
content it removes web pages from the
index that have low quality and
duplicate content not just that there is
one more algorithm called ranked brain
rankbrain is a processing algorithm that
uses machine learning to interpret
search queries that users search on
Google whereas the searched query may
not have the right keywords that were
searched for
for example
when you're searching for chocolate cake
recipes you will also get results for
chocolate truffle cake recipes on the
search engine results page Google Panda
and rankbrain send Bots to crawl each
and every website and as a result shows
high quality content on the top of the
search engine results page
next is our tip number four featured
snippet
these results are featured on the top
part of the page
Google programmatically chooses the best
answer from the third party website and
displays it on the featured snippet
here's what a featured snippet looks
like
according to ahrefs for a specific
search query almost 99 percent of web
pages shown in the featured snippet
already rank on serp's first page some
of the ways to optimize featured
Snippets are organize your content in a
structured way make sure one article
answers many similar questions use
eye-catching images and the last point
is to create answers with tables to
drive clicks and write dedicated
headings to answer featured Snippets
like is red meat healthy suppose you
want to create Snippets plan on creating
question based questions along with the
relevant keywords for ideas you can also
look at the Google search function that
is usually written in the blue color
and it reads out as people also ask so
now let's move to the fifth tip
image optimization according to sem Rush
image optimization will play a prominent
role in search in case the images on
your website aren't optimized make sure
to take care of them right now remember
to use high quality images relevant
images and use a suitable label for your
image file include images in your site
map as it becomes easier for the Bots to
crawl and finally use alt tags as
crawlers use it to classify the images
alt text is displayed on the web page
when an image fails to load on a user
screen it is also utilized by Google to
drive meaning from images
a well-optimized image can improve your
page ranking and increase the engagement
on it image optimization can help your
web page show up in the image carousels
on search engines
next we have semantically related
keywords
semantic search will have become an
important factor for ranking in the
future semantic keywords are linked to
the primary keywords they drive relevant
traffic on search engine result pages
a simple way to look for LSI keywords is
on Google serp
semantic search can be performed wisely
by writing content that targets the
question that your target audience is
looking for
remember to optimize content for topic
clusters instead of focusing solely on
keywords and finally use structured data
and pick your semantic keywords this can
also be done with the help of a
comprehensive keyword tool it finds out
semantically related keywords
next comes tip number seven building
quality links
building quality links to your website
is important if you are aiming to manage
a successful and long-term SEO strategy
building quality links cannot be ignored
in 2016 Google declared that building
quality links are one of their top three
ranking signals always opt for quality
over quantity
as building quality links to your
content can give your product and
category Pages a boost in scrps
let me share a few effective strategies
that will increase the number of links
pointing to your website dramatically
the first one
earn backlinks from relevant and
authoritative web pages next promote
your content regularly on social media
opt for guest blogging and influencer
marketing next take advantage of social
media platforms like Facebook Twitter
Instagram and start your own page then
participate in forums to engage with
your target audience start your blog and
attract your target audience with your
valuable content
finally get listed in the high quality
link directories this will help you
build links from authoritative websites
next number eight is local search
listings
local SEO is the practice of optimizing
a website in order to obtain traffic
from location-based searching it is the
best way to Market your products and
services to local customers
according to Google local results are
based on relevance distance and
prominence these factors help Google to
find the best match for your search
for this reason it becomes important to
have your nap details accurate and
consistent across the internet
sem Rush confirms that local search
listings will play a larger role in the
SEO strategies
suppose you want to know how to get your
business in the local pack
go to Google my business page and create
your own
for this it is also important to have a
strong backlink profile
next we have number nine that is improve
the user experience
for the past few years ux has become an
important ranking factor for Google
however more and more SEO Specialists
have gained an interest in ux
ux optimization is nothing more than
focusing on the visitor
consider the partnership of search
engine optimization and user experience
this way the search engine optimization
focuses on search engines and user
experience targets website visitors
so both share a common goal of giving
users the best result
this is what the content King app says
about the user experience
let me show you a few practices on how
to effectively leverage ux designs to
provide your site's SEO performance
simplify your site's navigation a good
site architecture helps to gain traffic
utilize ux design to SEO friendly
layouts which means make content easy to
digest infused images and videos
whenever possible use ctas very wisely
and finally optimize for site load speed
optimize for mobile responsive design as
more than 50 percent of all the traffic
is now driven by mobile search
in case your site isn't mobile
responsive you will notice poor
engagement
and finally we come to our 10th and last
tip
that is using schema markup
according to search metrics 36 percent
of Search keywords bring up at least one
feature snippet that is derived from
schema markup schema markup is microdata
that every individual can add to his
website in order to give an enhanced
description to users on a search engine
results page
in simple words schema markup is used to
define website content
adding structured data will give your
website a significant SEO boost and
increase your rankings
some of the schema markup examples are
ratings and reviews image thumbnails
product availability and finally site
links
adding schema markup to your HTML is one
of the ranking factors
so if you are looking to become a
digital marketing expert then here we
have postgraduate program in digital
marketing so are you ready to boost your
career in digital marketing accelerate
your career and gain the skills you need
to thrive in the industry ready to get
started click the link in the
description box and embark on your
journey to professional growth and
achievement hurry up spots are filling
up fast greetings everyone this is Rob
Sanders and thank you for joining me
today we're going to talk about SEO
tools let's get started so if you're
doing SEO and you're doing on page and
off page SEO for an organization or
website you're going to need some tools
to help you so you can't go at it alone
you can't do anything manually you have
to lean on tools to help you work more
efficiently help you gain an advantage
and so if you're doing SEO you're going
to need tools for keyword research
you're going to need tools to help you
with the technical aspects related to
SEO you're going to have to use some
tools for off-page SEO including
backlink monitoring and Analysis and
then there's tools for helping you track
where your keywords and Pages rank so
there's tools for every element of SEO
and today we're going to take a look at
some of the best tools out there on the
market to help you do your job better so
let's start with the keyword research so
with keyword research tools you can do
your job a lot more efficiently finding
the right relevant keywords I mean
that's really key to SEO is finding
keywords that are relevant to your
business product or service that you
want to rank for so you want to be able
to choose keywords with high search
volume and low competition so where do
you get those numbers you get those from
certain tools you also want to get
forecasts for certain targeted keywords
you want to be able to generate a list
of latent semantic indexing type
keywords keywords close to the keyword
you're trying to Target you want to be
able to select primaries second keywords
wisely so having a list of keywords or
certain data points will help you do
that and you want to be able to identify
the keywords that your competitors are
also ranking for so good keyword
research tool will help you do all of
those things so what are some of the
tools out there well look no further
than some of the free ones that Google
offers like Google Trends so Google
Trends is a good tool that you can lean
on if so if we look at Google Trends all
you need to do is trends.google.com you
could type in a keyword I can look at
the volume or interest of that keyword
over time here I'm looking at football
versus American football and I could see
how it's trending then I could see you
know how it Trends in specific regions
of say the United States as my market I
can also look at other related queries
similar to football or American football
and so Google Trends is a good tool
helps you look at the volume helps you
look at what specific regions helped you
look at other keywords you know if you
want you can simply just do a keyword
search or you can actually just see
what's trending just by looking at the
latest stories and insights so we could
see International women's day you know
started to pick up steam it's picking up
more steam Etc so it's certain keywords
that tend to Trend well and you can pick
up on what those keywords are using
Google Trends now you could also use
another Google tool called Google
Keyword Planner the only difference is
this one's paid you need a Google ads
account so if we go into Google ads hey
you'll need to go to tools and you'll
need a Keyword Planner but when you're
in Keyword Planner you can find new
keywords so if I type in for example you
know online marketing and click get
started what the keyword tool is going
to do is give me the data that I need to
do appropriate keyword research it's
going to give me my keyword and similar
keywords it's going to give me the
average month and volume and the great
thing here is I can actually see the
trend for that keyword over time time
just by clicking on this little bar
graph so for digital marketing I could
see what the trend is over time I could
see what the competition is I could see
you know if I'm going to bid on this
keyword I could see what the bidding
range is so more important I could see
the volume and I could see the
competition here's my volume for this
keyword over the last 12 months on
average and here's my competition so
Google's Keyword Planner gives you the
necessary information you need to choose
relevant keywords wisely now there are
other tools out there that are paid that
help you look for Relevant keywords like
semrush or keyword finder that's a
freemium tool so there are plenty of
tools available to you you know another
tool I use that's not listed here is Moz
so if you just type a keyword let's just
type in the same keyword like online
marketing for example okay so what Moz
is going to do is going to give me some
volume it's going to give me some other
keyword suggestions okay it's going to
tell me how difficult that keyword is
and it's going to tell me who else is
ranking for that keyword so it gives me
again all the relative information I
need including competitive information
so you can use these two these keyword
tools moz's freemium summer paint some
are free there's plenty of tools out
there but these are the ones I would
recommend for keyword research now let's
turn our attention to technical SEO so
for technical SEO you're going to need
to use some tools there's no getting
around that because you want to be able
to monitor how your website is
performing I mean is it loading slow for
example does it have a lot of uh issues
with the website in terms of server side
rendering for example or server response
time what about four or fours and
redirects so you want to be able to
gather a lot of the technical
information that could Aid or prohibit
your site from ranking so you want to be
able to also you know look at what the
Bots are seeing and how they're viewing
your website so if Google goes to crawl
your site are they experiencing you know
a slow server time were they
experiencing Pages not found you also
want to see if you have a site map you
know what's the site map are these Bots
crawling your site or getting the pages
from assignment again you want to be
able to lean on some of these tools to
help you fix errors that you may
encounter like meta tags or four fours
or canonicals so you need a good tool to
help you manage all that and so I'm
going to go back to Moz starting out so
if we go back to Moz Moz is a good tool
it's an all-in-one it's a great SEO
platform so if I go to Moz and I log
into an account I can just go to site
crawl and so what Moz is going to do
it's gonna give me a lot of information
about how Moz is bot is seeing my site
okay so if I go to the site crawl I can
look at all the particular critical uh
issues that have experienced so I could
see four or four errors okay reiter X
related to that I could see Meta
descriptions missing meta descriptions
duplicate content so there's a lot of
different issues that my is detecting
for this particular site and the great
thing about Moz and this is why I use
mods as my SEO platform I don't work for
mods I've just used them a long time is
if you do have issues then they give you
ways to fix it so how to fix it section
so if I see missing description here if
I just click on review and get a more
in-depth analysis as to what the issues
are here but I can also click on the why
and how to fix okay and they're going to
give you some information about how this
is impacting SEO and what you could do
to fix the issue they lay out the issues
pretty prominently here you can see for
all the metadata issues I have I have
you know 142 total metadata issues I
have 10 title tag two Longs I have 122
missing meta descriptions so they lay it
out nicely here up the top so you can
kind of get a sense of what to work on
and again they prioritize it based on
the severity of the issue and then they
break it down into several categories
for example I just looked at metadata
issues you can see if I click on content
issues I have some duplicate content
that Moz is recognizing or missing or
valid H tags so Moz does a really really
great job playing all all the issues out
for you to recognize okay there's
another tool that I like to use called
screaming frog it's a pay tool so if we
go look here great thing I like about a
screaming frog it will crawl your site
and it will give you some list of issues
just like Mazdas of you know what it
sees in your site is it experiencing
four fours broken links are there any
redirects it's picking up duplicate
content site Maps you know they're
JavaScript issues how is it see the site
architecture so it really does take a
deep look at everything that could
impact your website from ranking okay
there are other tools out there like you
know deep crawl or woo rank they're both
paid and so pay tools are really great
as well it just depends on you know your
pricing structure what your budget is
but really when it comes to all these
tools they all more or less overlap and
do the same thing you just need to rely
on one of them to make sure that you're
able to see what the issues are now
there's nothing wrong with using two of
them just as a second reference point to
see if both are picking up the same
issue and of course I like to use search
console I always like to lean on Google
search console because that is the
source so search console will also you
know give you some feedback on how
Google's bot is crawling your site so
that's under the crawl error section
here so you can also you know use search
console to upload a sitemap so that's a
key to SEO you want Google to be able to
find your web pages quickly so you can
simply just signify to Google where your
sitemap is located so the search console
does a lot more gives you some HTML
improvements gives you some backlinking
and then the process of updating the
search console user interface so there's
a new user interface that you can use
with Google search console the great
thing is it's free and it has everything
you need to know about your website and
how it's affected by SEO organic search
the only thing you have to do with
search console is verify the site but
once you verify it it has all the
relevant information you need so let's
talk about backlink monitoring and
Analysis okay so this is related to
off-page SEO so you're going to need a
good tool to help you monitor your
website backlinks and backlinks are
simply just links from external sites
pointing to your site and you need to
keep an eye on what sites are linking to
yours are they spammy related sites are
they good at relevant sites or anything
in between so you need to really be able
to analyze what the good links are what
the bad links are pointing to your
website you want to identify and disavow
Port back links okay so you want to be
able to recognize which sites are
linking to yours that's actually hurting
you from an SEO standpoint and you want
to be able to do something about that
okay you want to measure citation flow
and Trust flow you want to check the
ratio of Link distribution in terms of
is it internal or external or you know
what kind of sites are linking to my
site are they you know social related
are they pure content related and then
you want to be able to track the number
of do follow and no followings you know
how many links pointing to our site are
actually telling Google and other Bots
not to follow the link or how many are
actually allowing the Bots to follow
that link if a bot follows a link it's
going to pass what we call link juice so
you're going to get credit for the
backlink if it's a no follow you're not
going to get credit for the backlink and
we want to be able to measure that and
so we want to have tools that will help
us do that so what are some of those
tools well hrefs is a good tool it's a
pain tool Majestic is a freemium tool
Moz again Moz is the tool I use news sem
rush and then again I gotta mention
Google search console so let's take a
look at some of these tools in terms of
backlink monitoring and Analysis so
let's start with Google search console
again it's free you just have to verify
your site and so if I go to Google
Search console I can look at links and I
can see what external links I have
pointing to my site okay so I could see
I have 17 000 in this example pointing
to the home page of this particular site
okay so if I click on that I can see all
the the top sites pointing to my home
page now from an off-page SEO
perspective do you want every backlink
or external link pointing to your home
page no so you want links pointing to
internal pages so you want to be able to
measure that so I could see with the top
linking sites are and I could also see
what the anchor text is so do what I
want my anchor text always to be my
brand name no I want it to be you know
keyword we're trying to Target search
console also gives you some internal
links okay one of the top link Pages for
internal links so from an SEO
perspective you always want to have a
nice balance of internal linking so this
report helps you understand what pages
are getting links and are the links
evenly spread so this is Google search
console this is the links report this is
totally free this is provided by Google
all you have to do is verify your site
now if we go over to Moz we type in a
domain any domain so I just typed in
simply unlearn okay Moz has some metrics
that are important to off-page SEO
including domain Authority so the higher
your domain Authority the better off you
are and so what helps a domain Authority
grow is how many quality links are
pointing to that domain and so here we
could see over
7500 linking domains to Simply learn so
what's important is we just don't want
any site we want quality relevant sites
pointed okay so we could see how many
total inbound links and then how many
ranking keywords we have okay so here
here Moz is going to give me kind of an
idea of what my domain Authority has
been over time they're going to tell me
the top followed links to this site so
they can tell me you know what are those
links pointing to my site and what's the
page authority of those sites okay here
I can get a nice graphical breakdown of
the linking domains by domain Authority
so you want pages with high domain
Authority pointing to your site so here
I could see 69 linking domains between
91 and 100 so that's really good we want
High relevant domains linking to our
site so just like search console I could
see the top anchor text being used okay
and I can see the top pages that have
you know good page Authority on the side
I could see following versus no follow
on internal and external links so this
is just the overview so mods really
really does break down for you you know
what those pages and linking domains are
so if I just click on linking domains
now I could get a detailed look for my
home page what domains are pointing to
our domain so I can see microsoft.com
has a domain authority of 100 YouTube 99
and so not only does Moz provide you
with the domains it also provides you
with your domain Authority score and
spam score so you want to keep an eye on
any particular site that has a high spam
score so having a site with a high spam
score and a low domain Authority will
hurt your domain and Page Authority for
that page so Mazda does a great job of
breaking it out and this is for any page
it doesn't necessarily have to be the
home page okay if I take a look look at
another example here Majestic so
Majestic again I can use a free version
of the tool they have their own metrics
citation flow trust flow so when they
say trust flow what's the link quality
all about okay citation flow what's the
link volume and they can get an idea of
how many external backlinks are pointing
to the site and what's the trend on that
referring domains so Majestic does a
really good job again some of the same
metrics that we could see here except
they go into detail about languages as
well so this is majestic and you got
search console you got a lot of other
tools and then I'm going to just revert
back to Moz because you want to be able
to compare link profiles if you're in a
competitive space and you're doing
off-page SEO you know Moz will help you
compare how your site stands against
maybe another competitive side or
relevant site so just doing this
analysis I can compare my domain
Authority spam score how many total
links you know how many external file
links or external no file links a
breakdown of linking domains so it does
a nice job of comparing one site versus
another that's going back to Moz and
that's what you want you want a good
tool that's going to help you do that I
mean there's other tools out there not
listed like bright Edge that will also
help you compare linking profiles so at
the end of the day if you're doing
off-page SEO you want to get a sense of
what sites are linking to yours are they
quality sites are they spammy what
anchor text are they using are they no
follow are they do follow you know are
they top domains how do you compare
against your competitors I mean all
these metrics are related to off-page
seos you want a good tool that's going
to help you measure this okay so let's
talk about rank tracking so when we do
keyword research we're looking for
Relevant keywords we find our relevant
keywords we sign primary and secondary
keywords to Pages we optimize those
pages we do off-page SEO and we do an
all this work for SEO okay we want to be
able to measure the fruits of our labor
we want to be able to measure how we
perform for on and off page SEO for the
keywords we covet in the pages they're
related to and so that's where rank
tracking comes into play so we want to
be able to track our website's ranking
and not just our website all the pages
we've optimized we want to be able to
measure are click-through rates and
Impressions we want to be able to track
the ranking for both desktop and mobile
for specific locations and we want to
identify top performing gaining and
losing keywords so in other words we
want to look at Trends is a keyword
ranking is it going up in ranking is it
going down and ranking if it's going
down and ranking then you need to take
action so you need a tool a good tool
for rank tracking so we can look no
further than again Google search console
it's free it's right from the source so
let's take a look at what Google search
console has to offer in terms of rank
tracking so if I go to Google Search
console and I put in a URL what it's
going to do is it's going to give me and
this is the search queries report it's
going to give me what queries people
have used to actually type into
google.com and it's going to be able to
tell me how many times my pages show
Pages showed up for that query it could
be more than one page so that's an
impression and if I did receive an
impression meaning did my page show up
in the organic listing then did I get a
click as a result and so in this case if
I got 68 Impressions and 10 clicks for
keywords somebody typed in that's a 14.7
percent click-through rate and so at
search console we'll also do is say hey
look for that particular keyword you
appeared on average in position 4.1 so
it gives you really good insight as to
you know what people are typing in and
how you're being found for those
keywords it breaks it down by Pages it
breaks it down by country breaks it down
by device so I could see you know mobile
I've had
899 Impressions over the last three
months on mobile and I received 33
clicks as a result my average position
on mobile was 2.6 so search console does
a really good job again this is free
information uh providing you the actual
keywords somebody's using on Google
search as a query and how many
Impressions you're receiving for that
keyword how many clicks click the rate
and then average position so in theory
the higher you are positioned on Google
the more clicks you're going to receive
so if I'm not positioned properly for
keyword let's say page two then I'm
probably not going to receive as many
clicks as I would like so that search
console there are other tools out there
like hrefs again does a good job of
tracking AMZ tracker we look at wincher
so there's some good tools out there I'm
just going to show you another one again
I'm going to go back to Moz for example
so Moz has a tool called so if I go back
into the account so Maz has a rankings
tool that you can look at to see where
your keywords are ranking so if you've
already chosen keywords and optimized
Pages for those keywords then you want
to be able to load those keywords into
Moz and so Moz allows you to do that and
so what Moz does they do a crawl once a
week and they'll be able to tell you
where you rank for all your keywords are
we moving up in the rankings are we
moving down how many keywords do we have
ranked between positions one and three
eleven through twenty four through ten
twenty one through fifty so we'll be
able to see where our keywords Rank and
so it gives you a breakdown here of
nationally in the United States where
this keyword is ranked and if it's moved
up or down and for what URL is it ranked
for and so you can label so the keywords
and and this is what you want to look
for in a good tool you want to be able
to organize your keywords and label them
so for all our brand keywords we want to
be able to label them branded because
ideally you don't want to optimize for
your brain keywords so maybe we want to
exclude our brand keywords and look at
our non-brain keywords in terms of
ranking and so you can certainly add
locations and look at specific locations
the whole idea between a good ranking
tool is to be able to measure you know
if a keyword is trending up or down okay
so I can simply look at a particular
keyword and I can see the trend of that
keyword and then you know if a keyword
it's not ranking then we want to wonder
why it's not ranking well is it
difficult is it not ranking because of
its difficulty or can we do a better job
of optimizing for that keyword and so
Moz also has a page optimization tool so
if you're not ranking for keyword you
can flip over the page optimization tool
then put in the keyword put in the URL
and mods will give you some idea as to
what you can further do to optimize the
page okay so that's Moz you know this is
hrefs so you can see ahrefs does the
same thing they provide you some
visibility average position how much
traffic you know where you're ranking in
terms of positions one through three
four through ten eleven through fifty
and so you want to be able to get a
sense of where my track keywords are
trending are they trending up are they
trending down and the whole idea again
Beyond a ranking tool is if you're
trending down you want to be able to
address why it's trending down so you
want to start with on-page SEO can we do
a better job of optimizing or off page
does that page need more backlinks so
that's why you need a backlink tool to
support your ranking and ahrefs does
offer up some competitor information as
well so you can see how your competitors
are performing so these are some good
examples of ranking tools that you could
take advantage of now there are also a
few important SEO tools that can be
helpful in different ways for example if
you're doing video so there are some
tools to help you measure how you're
performing via video for example vid IQ
so let's take a look at vid IQ so if I
load in say video in YouTube in this
example how to rank YouTube videos I
have a vid IQ extension loaded into my
browser in Chrome and so now I can get a
good eye sense of how many views the
duration the engagement rate the like
ratio how many people shared it on
Reddit but further I can look at how the
video is optimized so they're telling me
the title's too long here maybe shorten
it up but we have tags we have
descriptions we have cards we have end
screens it's been shared on Facebook it
hasn't been shared on Twitter okay it is
public we do have pinned comments and we
do have hearted comments and so this
gives me an idea of how we did in terms
of optimizing this particular video okay
so if we wanted to tweak it we could
tweak the title tag make it a little bit
shorter to help it rank better on
YouTube so you want to be able to use a
tool like this because if you have
videos then you want those videos to
rank and so you can certainly watch this
video on how to rank your YouTube videos
and in that video we do allude to vid IQ
so you want to be able to use a tool
like this because you know YouTube it is
a video portal but it's the second
largest search engine behind Google so
if you do have videos you want to be
able to rank for them and you want a
tool that's going to help you measure
and help you understand if you are
ranking if you're not ranking why are
you not ranking now for Content
optimization there are tools you can use
like SCS site checkup or site analyzer
are some good tools if you already have
Moz as an example just going back to Moz
as you already know I use mozz a lot so
they have a page optimization so you
could check the content and how you're
optimized your content so it's going to
give me some good feedback on you know
is your page title meta description are
they in line okay so it's going to give
you some good feedback on that you also
have again I have to allude to search
console you can always look at a
particular page in search console and
see if it has any errors as well so is
it duplicated meta description is it a
duplicated title tag is it any Pages
missing title tags your meta
descriptions so when it comes to content
you can look at search console you can
lean on Moz or you can lean on some of
these other paid versions like site
analyzer when it comes to traffic and
metrics look no further than Google
analytics there is a free version of
Google analytics as well as a paid
version so if I go into Google analytics
it's going to tell me all of my website
Behavior okay who's coming to my site
how they got to my site how they behaved
once they went to my site and are they
achieving the goals I set out for them
to achieve via conversions and so you
want to look at first in Google
analytics how much traffic you're
getting so if I go to Google analytics
if I go to acquisition all traffic
channels I should be able to see how
much traffic organic search is driving
over a period of time so I could see how
many users how many sessions then if I
click on landing pages I can see what
landing page they went to so I could see
the home page over a particular time had
over a thousand sessions I can also see
engagement from organic search are they
bouncing how many pages are they looking
at in the session after they landed on a
particular page are they staying on the
site along long time what's their
duration or are they achieving any goals
so analytics will provide me all that
information about how organic search as
a channel is performing the other thing
about Google analytics I like and that
goes back to the technical aspect of SEO
and that site speed so if you go to
behavior and you go to site speed
overview you'll be able to see how my
pages are loading what's the average
load time so they'll break it down for
you by browser by country and by
specific page so if I look at page
timings I'll be able to see what page is
loading slow what page is loading quick
compared to site average and so the
great thing about analytics is if I have
a page that's loading slow compared to
site average they'll actually provide me
with some suggestions so if I go to site
speed and speed suggestions what they're
going to do is they're going to have a
link in the report that's going to allow
me to click on it and I'm going to be
able to see what suggestions they can
provide so when this report loads I'll
be able to see what the speed
suggestions are for my pages so here I
could see the page I could see what the
average low time is of that page so for
example this particular page is loading
at six seconds ideally we want to have
you know three seconds or under maximum
so if I just click on this link here
they're giving me six page speed
suggestions so if I click on that I'm
going to go to another Google tool
called page speed insights and then page
speed insights is going to run for both
mobile and desktop for this particular
page and then this page speed insights
report is going to give me feedback as
to what I need to do to speed up the
load time of that page so here you can
see for desktop and mobile they're going
to give me some suggestions and
opportunities so reduce the server
response time properly size images serve
images in next-gen formats so all these
will shave off time off my page load
time and so that's what's going to help
me speed up the page load and that's
page speed insights you can get to to
from the speech suggestions report and
analytics so in theory the higher page
load time your chances of ranking on
Google organic search diminished so
Google wants pages that have very low
page load time that load quickly so
Google analytics is great tool for Speed
suggestions it's a great tool for
finding out what the traffic is doing on
your site how they're engaging and are
they achieving goals now there are other
tools out there from an organic
perspective like keyword it that's a
good keyword research tool for Reddit so
if you go to keyword it you'll be able
to see from a Reddit perspective what
keywords are driving volume these are
just the results but you can put any
keyword in there and get the results of
that keyword hey guys
welcome to today's session
my name is Sachin sehgal and I'm here to
talk about a very important tool Google
ads and out of all the ads we can create
under Google ads today we would be
talking about a very important one
Google search ad so this is going to be
very exciting this is going to be very
deep from my experience I can say I will
going to take you through a lot of
technical aspects and lot of
optimization strategies where you can
really bring down the cost down if
you're really paying high for your
clicks and conversion so please be with
me and I would try to give you the best
from my site great so let's just start
guys Google ads is something which we
have discussed in the last class if you
have seen my last session if you have
not we will leave the link in the
description where we talked about the
basics of Google ads and we also talked
about how to create this beautiful ad
account or a tool with a free Gmail ID
okay
we did talked about few more things that
how many types of ads you can create
just to give you the quick glimpse we
are on Google and when we type something
like if I want to do a data analytics
course
so I would type few things like a word
or a keyword or a query into Google
search engine and then Google as a
search engine would show me few results
the results which we see on the top we
are talking about these today you know
this is the topic or this is the kind of
an ad which we would create today in
this session this is called Tech Stat or
this is also called Google search ad
okay so this is the first type of an ad
you see or which you can create under
the Google ads there are few more just
like if you would go and search for any
of the e-commerce product probably by
winter
jacket
online
so then there would be results but in a
different shape and color and different
structure there is an ad which is a text
ad but on the top we are able to see
some more ads but they are not just text
they have a pricing they have a title
they have a brand name they have an
image of the product so they are called
shopping ads or product listing ads in
addition to that sometimes you know when
you go to a product a website like speed
test and you see the product ads there
but again in the different shape and
color so they are called
display ads because they've been
displayed on different websites and
different apps so why I'm going so fast
in explaining you different type of ads
because as I told you we have another
video created uh with the name of Google
ads for beginners 2023 you can just
check the link in the description and
you will able to get all this type of
ads and whatever the uh you know bidding
strategies to be used in basic in that
particular tutorial or that demo just
has to show you if you can see that ads
by Google so this is the display Adder
Banner just quickly I have shown you
three types of the ads but our Focus as
I said today going to be on a very
specific ad which
is the most important ad from the Google
ads family okay so let's just begin guys
when I come to Google ads this is how
the Google ad structure looks like
we have a Google ads account created
again I repeat if you don't know how to
create it please find the link in the
description to create the Google ads
account once a Google ads account
created then you would have a dashboard
like this okay in this dashboard you can
see there are campaigns there are ad
groups there are ads there are videos
there are landing pages so a lot of
things can be confusing if we are just
coming to this account or to this
beautiful tool for the very first time
so to just keep it very simple or to
explain in uh in a very simpler way what
I did is I just drawn this structure for
you okay so the structure says that you
have a Google ads account imagine that I
am a simply learn Google ads manager so
I am running the ads for all simply
learn keywords like data analytics
course digital marketing course or any
machine learning course python course so
whenever somebody types this so there is
a ad which shows like from Simply learn
probably you have to just assume because
currently I'm not able to see any simple
an ad here so data analytics course
India
and then probably we can see if there
are any
you can always change the keywords but
just to test time randomly changing the
words or I could have just written
simply learned specifically because I
want to go with simple learn only I have
researched a lot and I feel like this is
one of the best okay so probably there
is no ad though
still I would check
probably I have to just change the codes
so I will go for the another course
which is by simply learn again and then
probably we can expect any of the ads
running
because this is not a very peak time so
we are probably you know saving some of
the cost not running the ads at this odd
hour anyhow so we can assume that this
is the ad you know I am running for so
how we can create this ad how we can get
the best of clicks as I said it is not
the very best time to run the ad so this
is also kind of a change you know we can
bring into our ads by doing some
research so how all these things are
done we're going to be learning it okay
so when we come here to the dashboard
and when we see our dashboard looks like
this a bit complicated so we can be
confused we can be disheartened that I
have created the account by seeing uh
the first video but now I am all stuck
okay so probably I have to again wait so
the weight is over now we are here to
understand the whole structure okay so
let me just take a very simple example
suppose I uh I'm someone who's selling a
shoes okay because I have just said
simply learn probably let's just convert
it to any of the Google ads account of a
shoe seller probably I am Nike okay and
I am making the add for Nike shoes and I
am selling two types of the Nike shoes
today probably formal or Canvas OR
probably I am selling the casual or any
sports shoes and what I did I created
the campaign named it search ad
uh any month you know whatever the month
you have started with suppose November
so November 2022 that is the name which
I am giving name can be changed name is
something which is being put it up for
my reference so that after creating a
lot of campaigns I'm not confused in
which campaign I have to check the
results okay so I'm running the search
art for shoes for the month of February
or November or December 22 23 whatever
and then I open two ad groups into it
why I'm opening two ad groups under one
campaign because I'm selling two kind of
products under the shoes only I am
selling formal also
under the shoes only I am selling casual
also so what happens suppose I would
have just you know created one art group
and would have inserted or submitted all
the keywords of formal and Casual inside
one ad group then if somebody would have
searched a term called formal black
shoes then this ad group would have got
confused that should I show formal ad
shoes or should I show casual ad shoes
because what I did I have just got all
my keywords like formal casual Cricket
shopping jogging party office you know
all the mix of the keywords from formal
and Casual family into the same ad group
the moment any of these six keywords
being typed or been searched on Google
then this ad group would have got
triggered and then again randomly it
would have shown the ad of a formal or
ad of a casual because both of the ads
would have been under this okay but
after doing uh this bifurcation or after
doing this segmentation what would
happen all the formal keywords like
party shoes office shoes formal shoes
formal black shoes would go here
this ad group would trigger if any of
this keyword would search and
accordingly this ad which has everything
related to only formal shoes will be
shown and of course with that ad the
landing page is connected which would be
open you know when somebody clicks the
ad okay and vice versa if somebody would
have searched for a casual term like a
casual shoes sports shoes jogging shoes
running shoes then this ad group would
have triggered and then the casual shoes
ad with all the headline related to that
casual keywords would have been shown
and accordingly if somebody would have
clicked then the landing page of casual
shoes you know would have opened okay so
if this is clear actually you are very
much ready to uh dive into the Google
ads because many people takes a lot of
time to understand the structure because
uh you know maybe they are very much
confused at the art group level but I
have just tried level based by bringing
this example why I am creating two
different ad groups I why I'm not just
going with the same ad group you know
mixing all the keywords
second scenario could have been on a
second permutation could have been I
would have just you know probably
created two different campaigns all
together I would have named The Campaign
one with search ad formal shoes November
okay then only that only this part would
have belonged to the first campaign then
I would have created a different
campaign altogether and would have named
it campaign search ad
casual shoes November then this second
campaign or a second campaign can be
assumed here with you know with a green
color would have been drawn okay so this
is how on the structure it works like we
can always now create inside so let's
just see a few things uh before we
create the ad okay very important uh
requirement or rather I would say uh if
being the campaign manager of any any
any any company you name any startup you
name or any client you work with or
probably for yourself as well you have
to be very much sure how these terms
works like Okay so this terms when I
talk about is going to be bit inclined
towards the search ad today only and
when I talk about the display ad in the
next video then I would you know take
you through about the terminologies and
all the kpis of display Banner or video
ads okay so now if I talk about a search
ad a very important
um term which we should be aware of is
the maximum bid price
okay because we all know when we're
talking about this ad which is called a
text ad then we are paying on every
click okay that's why this is also
called PPC ad this is also called PPC
marketing or you can understand in a
very simple words uh Advertiser which is
Emirates this in this particular ad only
has to pay when somebody like Sachin
this movement clicking this ad I click
this ad I reach to the landing page of
this particular University or this
college and a certain amount is deducted
from this particular ad account and that
certain amount actually decides or
decided on the basis of the keyword
helped to show this ad okay so as an
Advertiser must have paid something to
Google ads for showing this ad for this
keyword okay so when I say a maximum bid
price it means it's a maximum bid price
of a keyword that's why now this would
be easy easier to understand by this
example suppose I want to run the ad on
the term called data analytics course
2022 what I did I have opened the Google
Keyword Planner you know I did talked
about this in the previous session but I
will take you through again how you use
a Keyword Planner smartly so I have got
this data from the keywords planner that
the average price I have to pay for this
keyword to show my ad is 5 to 10 Rupees
so what I did I just played a bit of
maths and I have bidded something over
the minimum bit price okay this is the
minimum bit price this is the maximum
bit price okay and this is what I've got
from the Keyword Planner so rather than
going for a very high price or the
maximum bit price to secure my position
I want to play safe and what I would do
I would just take a chance maybe 30 40
over the minimum bit range and then I
will see if the Impressions or clicks
are coming or not if this starts come
coming it means that my ad is accepted
and my keyword is you know winning in
the auction and I'm able to get the
clicks but if it is not picking then
certainly I have to increase my bid
price but coming back to the
terminologies what we're talking here is
once I have set it up my maximum bit
price of 7 rupees then my ad would start
showing suppose my ad shows for thousand
times today and every time when my ad
been clicked you know certain amount
being deducted there is a competition
there are other advertisers also you
know who are running the ad and after
showing my ad for the whole day Google
in the dashboard just shown that you
have paid average CPC of five rupees
only so I bid it for seven but by seeing
different uh you know factors like the
competition the demand and how many
times the ads got clicked what was the
position where my ad was shown I ended
up in paying five rupees for every Click
by the end of a day so the average CPC
sometimes you know people get confused
they have a CPC and the maximum
Enterprise the same no so maximum weight
price is something which I uh you know
submit to Google that this is the
maximum I can pay for my ad to show on
certain keyword for every click and I
have a CPC something which actually you
know I pay every day or you know in that
average of the duration your ad got
displayed or got clicks uh for every uh
click on that particular keyword okay or
the number of keywords if you have more
than one keyword uh submitted and
suppose I've got 100 clicks then you
know it's a simple match that my budget
which I have spent today is five rupees
for one click 500 rupees 400 click so
daily budget would be 500 rupees and
tomorrow if company says I need 300
clicks then of course my average CPC
which I have from the historical date of
yesterday you know I would just do my
maths and I will going to submit the
daily budget of not hundred rather 300
today so that in 1500 I can expect 300
clicks at the cost of 5 rupees per click
okay so this is a very simple of the
example to just make you explain how
things works you know you submit
something then on the basis of a lot of
factors you know Google calculates and
will gives you clicks and once you have
the data then you know you can just
understand how this all is working okay
last thing before we dive into the tool
is Keyword Planner so I just told you we
have done in the last class how this
works like so we go into tool and
setting and then we go into Keyword
Planner and show you in the account also
the Google ads account just after 30
seconds uh the screenshots over so your
Keyword Planner opens and then you
discover the keyword suppose I am
selling data analytics course so I would
just put my search term data analytics
course and then I'll click the get
result and then accordingly it will show
me lot of options and this is the
pricing I was talking about it gives me
the low price and a high price so I
would take the 30 40 percent over the
low bid price or the average price
between these both and that would be my
maximum bit price and after checking all
the permutations Google would show my ad
or either it would not show my ad also
there can be a chance so I have to just
wait for my impression and clicks and
the results by the end of a day and I
would you know I would know uh how much
the average CPC actually I'm paying for
each keyword okay so I'll show you all
those reports in a while uh that's it
right now let's just go and see few
things so the Keyword Planner will start
with suppose I start
um you know in researching all these
things my campaign is about data
analytics course
I'm making it for safety run probably
and I would go and I would just try to
you know search into planning my Keyword
Planner and then I will write a term
quickly here you know whatever I want to
show my ad for
suppose data analytics course as I said
okay let's check digital marketing
because we would have more
uh results so it's
easy to understand with a lot of results
because I would be able to tell you how
to sort and filter them down uh digital
marketing course and you can just test
it with any of the keywords I'm just
doing a random check
so once we are here we have a lot of
keywords in addition to what we have
submitted so the keyword which I have
provided is this and the result shows
that it had over 100k uh you know
monthly searches and of course in the
range of 1 million in the in the in the
month of 2021 to September 22 so this is
actually the average monthly searches
happened in between this period and uh
the advertise is actually paid as low as
44 Rupees to as high to 224 rupees okay
that can easily be uh you know converted
to dollars uh half a dollar or maybe
more than half a dollar UH 60 70 cents
probably and uh this is like going to be
a three dollars cost okay so what we can
do is we can see now there are a lot of
keywords been given and we can easily
sort them down here on certain you know
bases like you know suppose the monthly
searches are high or the bid is low and
all that stuff but this is quite you
know difficult when we have to sort down
here in the Keyword Planner so what I do
is I'm just going to talk about the same
you know like hi how I actually go when
I am working for my clients okay I have
clients here a lot of clients I don't
want to show you but yeah I have and um
suppose I just go and download this data
from here
and then this would be you know
downloaded in the Excel format and we
can just save it anywhere suppose I just
bring it here and then now I would open
the keyword sheet
I would have a data in my Excel okay so
I need this this one so this is the most
important column because I have to
highlight uh which column is important
and what is not required right now so
whatever is required I'm just I'll be
keeping with me and what I feel like is
not very important as of now I'm just
not going to be taking them so now there
are
five column which I have kept with
myself like
4 where we talk about the results
okay
this is not required this is not
required so I'm just going to be
deleting or hiding them okay so when we
talk about our competition index value
so this actually tells us that a
particular keyword is how much uh you
know from the competition point of view
is difficult to rank suppose I talk
about two keywords right now let me just
take
um a one with a lower score suppose this
one and I would take the higher or the
highest one probably is this one okay so
now I'm going to talk about a comparison
you know probably uh or or probably
let's say this this one because this has
a monthly searches which are equal and
uh you know from the uh compression
point of view they are very different
but the search has been same so if I
would stuck to something of this sort
that if I have to finalize between these
two so what I would do you know that's
something which we are talking here you
know if you have a kind of a combination
where we have to decide out of these two
so both of uh the keywords have been
very important if I would just check
from my naked eye or quick Scan they
look very promising they look very great
to me suppose and they have a equivalent
number of searches in the last uh you
know one year on the average monthly
basis but there is a difference between
the competition okay now people can be
confused what is this competition so I
would just make you explain in a very
simpler way Suppose there are 100
companies so there are 100 you know
ethic institutes or probably physical
institutes who teaches uh digital
marketing because we are doing online
marketing or you know traditional
marketing course online so so let's keep
it uh online uh institutes like simply
learn and all okay so what they have
done is in the last one year they all
have used these keywords to run their
ads you know to show their advertisement
or their digital ad on a Google space
okay when this data has been given so
this is telling me that out of those 100
advertisers or my 100 competitors
66 or a 66 percent advertisers have used
this ad
okay or have used this keyword to show
their ad okay and out of 100 33 or if it
is 100 then 33 advertisers have used
this keyword to show their ad okay so it
brings you know kind of a comparison to
US that probably these two keywords are
very much in demand you know like
equally from the searches point of view
because both have been searched equally
but whenever this has been searched then
there has been a competition where 66
people or 66 advertisers or 66 percent
advertisers are fighting to show their
ad okay and when this keyword being
searched as equally then only 33 percent
or 33 people or 33 advertisers are
fighting to show their ad on Google
space okay when I talk about 100 then it
seems to be okay where my AdWords look
like you know where my ad would show
because if I just go on a Google space
you know that only seven ads are shown
when you know when we go on a Google
search engine one two three and four and
then the rest three would be at the
bottom if they are shown at this moment
or not I'm not very sure so three would
be here somewhere so total seven adds
placement on the first page nobody goes
beyond first we know that 97 of the
worldwide audience don't don't go beyond
the first pagination okay so we have to
be on our first page so if I talk about
from the first page seven positions
point of view it would make more sense
so let's imagine there are only 10
advertisers of digital marketing course
so out of 10 if I take out 66 66 percent
then it means almost like six to seven
advertisers are fighting or have bidded
or probably are trying to outrank each
other to show their ad on the top or on
the first four versions of Google but
when I talk about this then only three
to four advertisers are fighting or have
bidded for this keyword to show the ad
on the first page so this actually is a
very important data sometimes we just
you know Miss it because it has not been
uh I think explained anywhere else that
what exactly this value is we only go by
the low medium high which is the very
first column I delete nowadays you know
I don't you know go by this because they
both come under the medium but there is
a big difference you know seven out of
10 would have been bidded for and only
three to four would have been bidded for
this keyword so never go by the high
medium or low just go by the index value
okay that's a percentage of The
Advertiser who are actually trying to
fight for the same keyword to show their
ad on the top okay this is how we you
know shorten or we get the best keywords
we try to get the best searched keyword
with the you know kind of a index value
between 50 to 60 less than that and then
we of course you know go for the bit
value or a bit price which is also on a
very lower side not a very high price
keyword we go with so this is the
criteria you know I actually follow and
that's something which you know you can
see I have also mentioned here you can
see that much uh you know we go for the
high search keyword and then we'll try
to get the low medium competition
keywords which of course less than 60
index value and then I put a price you
know kind of a price of my price you
know which is like if the low bid price
is 10 Rupees then I just make it 13 by
adding 30 to it so if the pricing is 10
so I would add 30 to it that makes my
price 13 and then I check you know uh if
in the first if the Impressions has come
it means my price actually been accepted
but if any of the keyword my price is
not accepted then I would again revise
the price by 20 30 and then would wait
from the secondary report and that's how
you know I keep changing for the first
two three days and keep seeing the
results and once the you know every
keyword gets pick up and I get the you
know it starts getting the stable
results then I uh just allow the
campaign to work uh you know on the
algorithm and uh you know I I see uh
results actually moves in the positive
direction when you give some time to
campaigns to read and to learn uh you
know from the audience Behavior okay so
this is about the keyword planning which
we have just seen
now moving to again a very important
aspect because campaign making is
something which I've already given you
the you know Glimpse in the last class
so I would again give you today but
before that I really you know wanted
today to speak on all these technical
aspects you know which works at the back
end so that's why my focus is more on
this uh presentation parallely I would
keep showing you the uh you know uh the
uh Google ads other demo and everything
okay so now when we move to the next
part next part is very important from
the
um add algorithm point of view so what
happens or what used to happen uh when
when the quality score you know which
I'm just trying to speak now I was not
there uh what used to happen the one who
used to pay the highest bid price used
to get the first position and the second
one used to get the second position and
the third bidder used to get the third
position so I have just brought into
this table suppose a Advertiser has been
at 8 rupee B10 C 15 and D 20 and when
the quality score concept was not there
so they actually been given the very
direct position this one first this one
second this one third and this one
fourth but they have realized or Google
has realized that the one who is paying
the most is not having a very good
quality of the ad uh his uh landing page
or the website it's is not working or
probably the pages which is which are
connected are not very relevant and the
keywords on which the ads been shown is
nowhere near uh you know when the
landing page is open so it it was like a
very negative impact on Google when the
reviews been checked and people or the
users who are clicking on those ads were
not happy so what Google did Google
brought us you know kind of um uh test
score or a check which is called quality
score for every keyword we bid okay and
this is only for the server chats that's
why I said on all the keywords we made
okay
I'll just show you the result on a
client side so when we submit our ad on
the basis of you know different keyword
we bid and the and the strategy we use
and the landing page we connected the
backend so what the system does is
system starts analyzing and starts
checking everything from top till you
know bottom from the start till the end
and I would just talk about the factors
and what impact it brings is so the
quality score the score which has been
given out of 10 is then been given to
every Advertiser on the basis of the
keyword suppose every Advertiser here is
bidding on the same keyword you know
let's let's
um assume that they all are running the
ad for the digital marketing course so
what would happen they would check and
on the basis of the you know factors
they would give a score out of 10.
suppose the a Advertiser who bid it for
the least had the best of the quality
score because of the reasons we'll just
going to talk about B got 8 out of 10 4
out of 10 and 2 out of ten so the one
who have bidded the most got for the
very least quality score probably the
reasons you know would be more clear
once we talk so how this allow we're
going to impact the whole position
system is that their Google rank not
Google position okay there is a Google
rank kind of uh kPa can be understood
your Matrix which is a product or a
multiplication of what you bid and how
much quality score you were able to get
so 8 into 9 being 72 10 into 8 brings 80
15 into 4 bring 60 and 22 is 40. okay so
the combination of a good pricing and a
good quality score got B bidder as a
first position okay and the one who got
the best quality score but still paying
very less from the average price in
globally is you know brought the Google
position or add position to Second and
then the one who was spraying very high
but the quality score was below average
which is a Force 5 6 is average price
average score they've got into third
position and the one who was paying so
High probably would not get a position
because this is the maths from the match
point if we have got these numbers if
the quality score would have been below
5 then the ad would not have got any
position rather because Google always
tries to you know show the ads which are
the best uh for the users you know
because Google always pays very
importance to the users behavior and
users
um you know expectations so and when I
said that I think you were able to
understand more now how the factors you
know which which actually results in
these quality score is
um like relevant score like by relevant
score means when you type a query or a
person would come here would type a
query so he doesn't know that this is
called a keyword we as a digital
marketers know this is called a keyword
for them it is a normal query because
they are about to start a course where
they would be taught about all these
things but right now they are not very
aware you know very much aware of these
things so they are putting a query when
they put the query they want to see the
ad or add extensions or add description
relevant to what they have searched and
when they see all these three things
here with the search you know what they
made they would definitely going to
click more and Google only earns when
somebody clicks so it means Google
making Revenue only when somebody is
clicking so from that perspective also
Google always tries to pay you know or
rather give more score and give a better
position to the ads where all the
components of the ads are perfect are
relevant and the ones who starts getting
more clicks in the very first hour or
first day okay so the important factor
which after the click is the landing
page so when somebody opens this so it
has to be very relevant to this query
and do whatever being shown outside they
cannot just show anything here which is
not relevant to the ad which actually
been shown outside so all these uh you
know factors in combination gives the
quality score very important factor is
CTR which you must have understood when
you know we I added you know explained
in the last session the basic one but if
you do not aware of it so CTR is called
click through rate okay and I click
through rate is a ratio of clicks to
impression
okay it is a ratio of clicks to
just a spell check okay so suppose today
when we are saying ABCD so let's see
these are this is a or this is B and
this is C and I've got you know
equivalent quality score on the basis of
all what they have done okay their
landing page their ad their description
everything is very much common so Google
in the starting of the day you know when
the ad actually started to show for
everyone uh you know giving them a very
good quality score probably of five okay
and when this quality score of 5 been
given to them then the other factor
which actually adds on you know to that
algorithm is the CTR so CTR is I just
told you is the ratio between click to
impression so now they all have a same
quality score but this got 100 clicks
out of the Thousand Impressions been
given today this got 50 clicks out of
the Thousand Impressions given today
this got by any mean probably 200 clicks
out of the Thousand Impressions given
today okay every time this this search
is happening here digital marketing
course so these
ads are very much visible equally so all
got thousand Impressions thousand
Impressions thousand Impressions but
this got 100 clicks this got 50 clicks
and they've got 200 Clicks in the very
first hour or maybe in the next two
hours okay so this CTR you know when we
are talking about 100 out of 1000 to 10
percent This Is 50 out of thousand it
means this is going to be five percent
and 20 uh sorry 200 out of 1000 means
twenty percent of the CTR so Google was
actually benefited or made the most of
the revenue and you know clicks have
come from here because it is almost like
a double or a four times of this so
because of the high CTR the quality
score of a force you know every every
Advertiser would improve but this one
would be improved from probably from
five to seven and this would you know
probably from five to five point five
and this is probably from five to six so
because of that quality score has
improved and uh you know because of the
high CTR this ad has got so this
position will be changed and this would
you know probably would get the first
page on the second position and at the
end of a day this ad has to pay or
Advertiser has to pay lesser because
it's quality score increase we have just
seen it is you know almost like the uh
you know inversely proportional the ones
who are actually paying or the ones who
are having the best of the quality score
are paying the least or has to pay the
least okay so this is all basically you
know can be checked once your ad starts
running so I will just open the clients
account uh where you can just see this
with
you know better
understanding you were able to get out
of this
hopefully I'm able to show you from okay
I'll just see because I have multiple
advertisers you know
but I cannot just show for all so let me
just check if I can show you how many of
the older one
just wait it is actually asking you some
verification
okay
it's taking too much time
yeah it's just done now
so once this is done
so I'll just take you to one of the
accounts where
my main focus will just show you how the
quality score report look like and then
you know you know you will get a fair
idea but all the factors you have to be
focusing to bring your quality score
high or two take your qualities for high
okay
so I'm just going to open the search ads
because we're talking about a search ad
here only and suppose if I just go into
this
Campaign which is of course you know not
running right now but I just want to
show you how you check the report and
all suppose this is the campaign you
have run for and you got 75 clicks at um
you know
um app with CPC price of 40 PESA and you
have just given this much pricing and I
have put it for many keywords but I
wanna see which keyword had got the best
of the quality score and how the
qualities have been given and all okay
so once you reach to the keyword report
here you know at this level then you see
um uh you know uh the kpis or metrics
here which gives the quality score out
of 10. okay you can see here very well
and every keyword being given you know
if there are 10 keywords I don't know
how many keywords we builted for we've
bidded 50 keywords okay and you know you
can see all the keywords here and every
keyword being given the quality score
out of 10 okay because their CTR which
was the last part which I've explained
you the ratio between the impression two
clicks got the above average so they
give below average average above average
so above average is best actually for
any of the factors so the CTR is above
average the landing pages above average
and their ad is above average means all
are perfect then they got the 10. the
moment anything goes below average or
probably to the average suppose you can
see this is above average for them this
is above average for them but they're
landing page experience from this
keyword point of view is only average
their quality score has come to eight
okay if we go further down uh let's see
anything where two of them yeah so here
the kids ride on is a keyword where CTR
is also not as high or as great you know
to as compared to the other keywords
which we have seen and also the landing
page is not as relevant to the keyword
so there are two factors like ctrn
landing page has come to average as
compared to the Android 11s which is
above average so their whole qualities
for got impacted which actually came
down from 10 to 8 and then seven for
this particular keyword and last not PC
if I just take you to somewhere where
something is below average has come now
one is above average one is okay they
are getting clicks but probably the ad
is still not very much relevant to the
keyword okay so they are below average
above average has brought the quality
score to 6 out of 10 which certainly
would have you know impacted on the cost
and also to the position okay so this is
something which you would see
when you come here also you can check
one more thing here suppose you have
bidded for your keyword and your bid
price where you are paying for is
maximum bit price let me just see where
that column is
so otherwise I would just add that
column so that you can learn that part
as well
okay
[Music]
just wait okay so this is basically
CPC price is being given in the average
cost 2.50 is the cost for every click
and we got 249 clicks so got 623 you can
just check the maths it's always good to
cross check so 249 clicks multiplied by
the CPC price which is 2.50 rupee would
give you 6 22.5 which is the cost you
know or the keywords uh you know we made
it for and the total clicks we have paid
okay and the
maximum beta price suppose you know you
have got uh the maximum bit price of uh
one rupee and you paid 17 PESA 1.66 and
all and then what happens you wanna
secure your position suppose the very
first page bid you're seeing that you're
getting the position but you're not
getting the first page then here because
this campaign is not running so I'm just
giving you the hypothetical example so
whatever the pricing you would have
given for the particular keyword suppose
we talk about these three keywords right
now a particular one keyword uh I
suppose so this is something which I'm
you know trying to show on a one rupee
cost but to show on the first page it is
saying that you have to pay 1.5 okay to
show on the first four positions here
one two three four it is saying that
probably you have to pay 2.5 and to get
the absolute first position which is
going to be the top most it would tell
you that you have to probably pay five
rupees you know you bring one it is
asking 1.5 the first four it can be paid
for 2.53 or this has to be five so you
can always go and change your you know
bid price for the particular keyword
okay so there are ways to do it suppose
if I'll just go here and I just go to
the edit I can change my maximum CPC bit
price for this particular bid or a
keyword like 25 rupee okay because I'm
not changing for all the keywords so I
have selected that particular keyword
and I have made the change to this
particular keyword to five rupee so if
you know the average price was one and I
was not getting the keyword uh from this
keyword the position secured on the
first page or the first absolute
position and I want because this is the
most important keyword for me then I
would just come here and would check the
pricing okay this says five rupees you
have to pay for the top position so I
will just go here edit and would change
the bid price or a maximum CPC bit price
of this particular keyword you can do
for all you know you have to just of
course you know select all of course but
if you would do for all then it you can
really impact your whole budget okay so
try to go for the keywords where you
really feel like it is required and
always go by the quality score it has
you know it has a very good quality
score so I should be paying or I should
be ready in paying uh the maximum price
which actually Google is asking me to
pay to secure my first absolute position
and certainly that would increase the
chances of clicks and certainly if
clicks are there so conversions can be
expected too okay so this is all from
what I've just taught you as of now
now I will just move to the campaign
making though we have done as I told you
last time but I will try to make it
again so that we can quickly see how the
Google ad search ads or the search
Google ad created okay so if I just go
to the campaign uh My Demo account so if
you just go to the Google ads account
the dashboard and then I would come to
the campaigns
I would just click Plus
new campaign
and whatever the you know
objective is you can always go for
website traffic or without a guidance
because this would have all the settings
inside the same more important part is
what we select next so we select search
campaign because we are making the ad
for the search Network you can always
test for website traffic that would not
make much difference and click continue
I will talk about the conversions and
remarketing in a separate session
altogether so we are not doing the
conversion and remarketing today we are
making a normal search ad with all the
strategies we have just understood and
with adding the extensions to the ad as
well today okay website visit and
suppose my website is just open safety
learns
uh landing page
so that I can make the ad for simple
Universal marketing as a demo ad of
course not a
mean AD
so copying and just putting in here I
have to just put a you know website
domain that's it I don't have to bring
the whole landing page here and then I
can just name it probably November
search ad
and then I will just go and continue
start new
and then I'll just select my bidding
strategy which is going to be clicks
and of course from my Excel I would
learn that okay my bid price which I'm
going to be paying uh you know is
certainly in the range of something like
probably 50 60 and I have just told you
that I bring my price kind of a thing
into this like I always bring like this
and then
let me just delete all the other columns
which are not required
so this is the sheet which I did explain
to earlier with the index value and all
so my price what is my price like so I
always pay 30 40 extra to the low bid
price so I can you know just get the
formula here like
this
Plus
this 30 percent
okay so that is just going to make it 57
so you can just understand 44 plus 13
going to bring 57 and I can just drag it
and now I've got the average suppose
these are the you know keywords which I
have finalized just assuming so these
are the keywords which I have finalized
probably because of x y z factors such
as an index value and all that and I see
that my pricing is varying from 35 to 89
so maximum being 89 so what I would do
keeping that in my head I was going to
give the limit to my bid price and I
don't want to pay anything extra or more
than 90. okay so this is something which
you can do on this particular level
and then you move ahead and you remove
this because you just want to keep your
ad on the Google search and then you go
down you select your countries you
select your location if you want to show
the ad in all the locations then you
certainly can just go and keep the very
first option open which is all countries
and territories if you want to just show
your ad
um
in a particular country like you know
right now if I just go India so the
whole India would see your ad and if you
want to go for a manual locations like
suppose I want to select any of the
states or cities then what I would do I
would just probably take daily so Delhi
would be targeted like this okay or
probably I just want to Target the state
of Texas here so I just would go and
Target the whole state or if I want to
Target any of the provinces of Canada so
I would just go and take the uh
provinces of Ontario Canada and I would
just Target the whole Province and now
if I also want to go for any of the uh
PIN codes suppose I want to Target to a
certain pin code then I can just go and
Target the PIN codes like this so it is
up to us that we want to go worldwide or
if you want to go for a country specific
if you want to go for us State specific
or if you want to go as a province or a
pin code specific okay otherwise if you
suppose
um a restaurant or if you are a you know
somebody who only delivers into certain
radius then you can just leave all these
options and you can go and advance
search
and then you can go to radius and you
can just bring this whatever you
understand better in India we understand
kilometers better maybe the person us
would understand miles better so we just
go and take that two kilometer radius
and probably I am the cake shop in Delhi
so I'm just going to search my location
this is my location and now we're just
going to Target people around 2
kilometer because I don't deliver
outside two kilometers so it's all up to
us how we're gonna go uh this is called
radius targeting or geofencing when we
go to the locations we can also learn
one thing suppose I want to show the ad
to the
um whole country India I have targeted
at the same time I am not delivering in
um uh in in in Mumbai okay or probably
in Karnataka you know Bengaluru where
the city is okay or probably I'm not
delivering in any of the uh northern
states like haryana Himachal Punjab so
what I would do I would just take Punjab
suppose for example and I'm just going
to exclude that okay so what would
happen now my ad would show in all these
states and all the cities of India but
just not in Punjab okay so I can save it
that's how you go about the location
language is you know in which language
the users will uses the search engine
and all so you can keep it all languages
that's the best and
audience we don't cater here much
because we are doing the search ad which
actually shows the ad on the basis of
keywords and location only so in the
display ad we're going to talk about
this uh one and that would be the next
video I would create so we're going to
learn a lot of things from the audience
segment in the next display ad and then
the more settings comes where you talk
about the add rotation so add rotation
is already default being selected as the
perform best ad if because the nowadays
the ad actually been created a
responsive and dynamic so when we'll
reach to the ad level I'll show you the
headline changes for every user the
description sometimes changes for the
user what I mean is if Sachin is
selecting or you know writing this
keyword so probably this headline is
shown to be and after one hour if I'll
come again and put search the same term
so the headline from the same Advertiser
could be different or the description
could be different so that's how these
anime cards works like okay so once you
are done with this okay the start and
date is important you know the basics
from the previous chapter so I'm just
going a bit faster in here so you would
select the date and
then if you want to schedule this
campaign for a certain period like
suppose you don't want to run on the
weekends so you can just select Monday
to Fridays and you know our timing
whichever suits you suppose just like a
very common time of 8 AM to uh you know
the late nights like 23 45 and you don't
want to run the weekends if you want uh
Saturday Sunday to be you know 24 hours
then you don't have to put any timing so
that goes like 24 hours for Saturday
Sundays and then you click next and you
reach to the next level
where it will just going to ask you for
certain things like keywords you want to
submit and the ad you want to run for
and the ad copy you know you have to
create okay so once you come here it is
the you know work you have done so you
can just copy paste them and you know
bring in there uh and otherwise these
all keywords are the ones which Google
has suggested you from you know the page
which you have submitted okay so the
landing page is this so I'll try to
change the landing page first so that I
can get more appropriate keywords and
then it would mean to search again on a
scan again for us update keyword
suggestions of course we can always
click on and now the keywords would be
more digital marketing oriented because
this landing page will be scanned by
Google and this would show a certain
results which would of course going to
be digital marketing oriented but why we
don't just uh you know use them because
we don't know uh what is the pricing of
these keywords is what is the
competition of this keywords is how much
the monthly search has been so we go by
our own maths we we calculate we do all
this free homework on the Keyword
Planner sheet just like we did today and
then we bring them here by deleting all
what they have actually submitted or
suggested us okay and once this is done
then we ensure that our keyword uh uh
you know in the headlines and everything
been used how that copy is created I'll
just show uh you some you know strategic
part of it ensure that your landing page
is correct and it is opening there you
know otherwise your ad would not be
approved secondly always give a display
path display path is something which is
added after the ad or the landing page
link suppose I'm selling online
digital marketing so I would just going
to write whatever I want to show
okay
probably I'll just keep it here
so that works okay so now it has
combinational marketing and then the
part comes where you know you have to be
foreign
extension once the ad is created so
headlines and all so the headline is
something which shows
you know you know the basics where I'll
be fast again
under the landing page link this blue
which actually uh you know brings the
most of the engagement or which actually
appeals the user to click it is
something in blue which is you know
going to be the headline so we have to
be focusing very much on bringing the
best of the headlines here so that we
can get the best of the clicks because
you know once the click increases the
CTR increases CTR increases the quality
Square would increase quality Square
would increase your cost you would come
down and your position would rise so you
have to ensure that your headlines your
clicks everything is in you know in a
line whatever we have learned so your
headlines right now has been given these
of course they are not very relevant so
we're going to just bring the headlines
which we feel like are more relevant to
the ad we are showing okay and
I'm just going to get the headlines as a
suggestion been given
okay and
we can have more ideas from here by
clicking this so they are not giving any
so we can always have from the keywords
which we have submitted so probably
digital marketing course online
try to get your best keywords here
this is okay
this is nice this can be changed
digital
marketing course
online is not taking so this Marketing
Online probably I'll just take because
course I already submitted and then I
can take few more like social media
marketing I just seen
or whatever the length it would accept
I'll take otherwise I'll delete the rest
this is the one and I should ensure that
I have at least 10 headlines or 12
headlines so six been given and headline
section actually you know been given egg
a half blue and then I would see
headlines which are unique so unique you
should have um uh you know online
availability key benefits and offers and
all or call to action so enroll
register
today
or free demo
then we'll talk about
you can see the moment I've added the
headline this the strength has changed
100 plus
tools for free
job
assistance
program
okay so I'm just adding few random
things I'm just not paying much
attention but yeah of course we would
have seen these headlines in any of the
acting companies ads uh include some
popular qos popular keywords could be
your brand name as well so simply
learn
courses online
of hopefully the spelling is fine and
we can batch for
professionals
oh
[Music]
um
just a batch for professionals
and that's it you know because I already
added a lot of keywords a lot of red
lines probably Ravens so I would just
not work on the headlines anymore uh
I'll see you know if deception doesn't
takes it high then I'll just add one
more but right now the description is
also not giving me the full uh tick like
in the headline unique and the headlines
been given so I'll just try to bring the
description so simply an online to do
online that's great that's great so just
try to get something from Google itself
let's see what they have given so I'm
just going to bring this one
okay so that it has been taken from the
landing page itself so that would make a
difference to
uh the quality score simple digital
marketing courses focus on so we're just
going to put
our courses focus on skills
co22
focus on
else like success
so we're doing this one here so they
has been picked up so now you can see
this has also been picked up and the
last thing I would do is now going to
bring some headline uh again you know
I'll just check probably
uh digital marketing
notification I'm not sure if this
headline I have submitted earlier or not
but I'm just going to test it out okay
so
you should
yeah
training
so now it has you know come down to good
and uh that's the best you know right
now we can do of course you can take it
further but yeah that doesn't
um matter if you are just stopping it to
get this one completed you have to just
ensure that all the keywords all of the
headlines are relevant just do not
overdo 10 to 12 are okay okay once this
is done your ad is created you can just
click done and you can click next
and then your budget so we just
discussed about the budget when I was
explaining we'll just take you back so
because you know that your average CPC
price would be around 80 you know
whatever the pricing you have just got
from here if you know the sheet and I
was explaining you so the the bit price
which you have submitted for you know
when I told you is like something which
is in this range uh like 80 90 whatever
it is so you know that bit price would
come down to 90 and you need
um at least 100 clicks today so 90 into
102 mqp your 9000 daily budget so
because you know that you know you would
end up in paying maximum 90 rupees per
click because that's the maximum bit
price you have submitted if that comes
down to 70 80 60 then of course your
clicks would increase but right now
though being very uh you know hypothetic
hypothetically thinking that okay I
would pay 90 rupees per click at Max
because that is what I submitted so to
get 100 clicks I have to pay 90 into 100
which would be 9 000 your you know
delivers it has to be so we would have
come here and you were just going to
change it set a custom budget and you
were going to bring down 9000 Rupees
here okay so on that yeah I have a CPC
whatever it would be you would get the
number of clicks if you have a CPC goes
down from 90 to 45 then of course you
are not going to get only 100 you'd
rather get double amount which is going
to be 200 okay once that is done then
you just click next and your budget goes
uh you know your campaign goes for a
review
and then you can add the extensions from
outside okay so they're just giving you
some of the uh you know kind of uh
suggestions so let's see uh there is one
issue in the ad
let me just check that first
let me just see
you can always fix it
with that foot again you're not going to
give you the option of um publishing you
know till you fix it but it is not
clickable or not no
uh what is the problem
I'll just go away from here you know
sometimes those links doesn't work so
let's see what is the issue
one product names
okay so because just to do that the
better limit part I have not given the
space so that is something which is not
acceptable by them
I just want to put like this skills like
this and
now so these all small things you know
they do
take care of so here only because you
have come down so why not you know just
to see the extension here itself because
that would I'm going to save our efforts
by going from outside so when you see
the ad you see some extensions here like
you know when you have created the ad
right now so you have created on detail
this limit okay this is the elements you
have put it up right now the landing
page the headline the description but in
this ad by Emirates you can see more
links like applied to IMS learn how
industry so one is landing page and
three different uh Pages or a sub page
has also been shown in this same ad how
they are done so they are done through
the extension called site link okay so
you can see here if you go down after
the headline there's an option to have
the site links here okay so you can just
click Plus
here itself you know I'm not submitting
the ad because I wanted just to show you
from here itself and then you can go
down because in your case these would
not be given because mine are already
created yours or not so you would go
down and you would create the new South
new site link from here and you can just
give a name suppose download
brochure
and then you can give a URL of that
download brochure page right now I'm
using this URL and I'm just going to be
adding my own made page
like this like this has to be the
landing page which is workable for the
downloading version of course so this
would be added and then I can just go
and probably add
um
testy nails
and reviews
okay so somebody wants to read the you
know testimons and reviews of when they
see the ad so you can see that on the
desktop how that would look like so they
would have an ad and then they would
have these four links involved which you
have just seen the Google when I show
new so final URL of reviews can be given
which would directly take them to the
page where the reviews being given and
uh site 2 could be anything you know
which can just see
um industry ready modules or the fee
structure you know the fee structure is
something which people always wants to
just know
from the uh very first glimpse of the r
itself so I can just maybe
take them to the page where fee is
actually been you know talked about and
the last could be uh maybe tools
provided
the tools and
certificates
you would get so that can also be one of
the links which people would very much
interested in you know clicking and
checking okay so you would see the the
ad in certain shape you would have a
normal headline uh the description which
you hopped it up and then four links
where people can directly reach okay and
then you know this had to be saved here
and you can always see the preview which
I've already shown you but yeah this is
how that would look like so you add
your ad and your four
extra links which actually been added
okay so this is one which you can apply
now
and now your ad has the extensions in
addition to that you might have seen
somewhere that you know your ad as the
number as well sometimes you see the
number being given here I believe right
now it is not showing any of the ads
with the number but the you know uh
generally have when advertisers have
nowadays the numbers in addition to the
headline and everything okay so you can
add that as well by just going up and
you can see there is an option of calls
okay okay let me you can add from here
uh certainly I can show you wow you know
you can just go down and add the number
by clicking your
country and you know giving your number
here it will just be cross checked by
some verification and all so that is
done you can save it so you can see what
actually I was showing you you know I
would just show you
um from outside also that if by any of
the uh you know
um that is done that we have corrected
so you don't have to be you know
uh worried about so if I just click done
so that should not be there if it is
still there I have to check now which
spacing it is actually talking about
um
actually I have unacceptable spacing
contains comma and I think I have just
corrected it but it is not taking maybe
I have to just
um
delete the whole description properly
that would be something which
and I would save our time
okay so you're not adding the
description though
just click done so this is actually you
know kind of a bug because that is
something which has been deleted rather
in front of you so this is not um
taking but I will just click next and
probably this would now be not the error
in which we would see
so you go for a review so what I was
saying I did shown you from outside the
you know the the campaign was created
from the ad itself how the site link is
connected and how the uh call been added
for now the publish campaign you can see
because that ad error actually been
rectified so if by mistake you know you
just forgotten that you have to add the
call number or extension you know which
we just started so but you don't have to
be worried because once you back to the
dashboard you know where you would see
all your campaigns certainly you would
see your this campaign as well in which
you had just created then you can just
go inside the
um add group and then
you can see there is ADD and assets
just click that
so there is an ad which you just created
and there's an assets
you know where you could see the
extensions and all like you know you
just have added today now we just added
this site link and this number so if I
want to add again or if I would have
forgotten then what I can do I can just
go and take from here suppose if that
call extension was not added there you
know when I just added you would come
here in the assets you would click that
plus button
and then you would just go to the call
and you would see the same kind of a
preview which you have seen inside the
ad when we were creating okay nothing
different it's just like the you know
where you do it you know either you do
when the ad was created or otherwise you
can just go uh let the campaign be
created published and you can come from
outside you can click the add an assets
you can go to plus and you can create
any of these extensions I will talk
about more in the coming you know
tutorials and demos uh and the sessions
but today you know we'll wind up here I
just uh you know wanted to give you the
thorough learning on the Google search
ad with the extensions and also the main
agenda for today was to make you
understand how these you know terms
works like and how the keywords can be
researched how you can bring your own
pricing to the keywords how can you save
the cost and of course to understand how
the quality score works like you can
have a lot of videos on a YouTube where
you can find the quality score of Google
ads working do I try to you know bring
everything under this session but still
if you want to go for a deep learning
you can always search more and research
more so if you are looking to become a
digital marketing expert then here we
have first graduate program in digital
marketing so are you ready to boost your
career in digital marketing accelerate
your career and gain the skills you need
to thrive in the industry ready to get
started click the link in the
description box and embark on your
journey to professional growth and
achievement hurry up spots are filling
up fast
now let's go into the social media
marketing tips and tricks
number one set up your goals
now what good will your actions do if
you don't have a goal in mind the goal
of your marketing strategy may be the
driving force behind every decision that
you make and this is exactly why setting
up goals is very important moreover your
marketing efforts have to align with the
goals of the organization
here are some things that you need to
keep in mind while setting up your goals
first of all your goals need to be
quantitative for example you need to
have a thousand conversions by the end
of the quarter or five thousand
followers on Instagram by the end of the
month and so on
number two you need to stick to a
consistent deadline this gives weight
for each of your options and number
three make sure your goals are smart now
smart refers to specific measurable
attainable relevant and time-based
now let's go to number four like I
mentioned earlier your goals need to be
aligned with the marketing strategy
and alongside these goals there also
needs to be the North Star metric now
what is the North Star metric well this
represents a main goal or a fixed
reference point to ensure that your team
is on the right course this North Star
metric will also give your team Clarity
and focus
now let's have a look at some popular
North Stars there's increased engagement
greater conversion rates more leads
generated app downloads and so on
now let's go to number two understanding
your audience
social media allows you to interact
engage and build relationships with your
Audience by understanding what they need
want and desire you can deliver content
in a way that makes your product or
service the answer that they're looking
for
there are also other ways that you can
understand them better
this could be surveys to determine the
issues that bother them the age
demographics of Their audience
by conversing with them in forums
responding to their comments and blogs
and social media taking up their
feedbacks of suggestions into
consideration and acting on them and so
on
now here's an example of different
channels and the audiences that use them
now here well we've taken a personal
example here is simply learn now simply
learns audience is predominantly working
professionals and graduates
unacademy has high school graduates and
baiju app has high school students as
users
now let's go to number three determining
the right social media platform
now when performing social media
marketing choosing the right platform is
really important
When selecting them you need to ask
questions like why you're using that
particular platform who you will reach
with this platform what content could
work best on the platform and is there
any content that was unique to that
platform like for example YouTube and
then there's the video
answering these questions will help you
zero in on a platform for you
now while there are several platforms
available for you to choose from let me
tell you about some of the major ones
there's LinkedIn Facebook Instagram and
Pinterest
now let's talk about the purpose of each
of these platforms LinkedIn is a
professional Network that's best suited
for B2B audiences
for Facebook well just about everyone
has an account on it
content that is related to news or
entertainment usually finds success on
Facebook and then we have Instagram
visual content works best on Instagram
now although it works well for static
images and short form video It Doesn't
Really drive a lot of traffic to your
website
and then finally we have Pinterest
Pinterest is also limited to static
images however it's highly effective at
driving traffic to your blog
now let's go to number four setting up a
social media calendar
a social media calendar demands the
message you want to convey to your
audience it also consists of information
regarding the different kinds of content
that will go up on the social media
platform
let's have a look at some of the most
popular types of posts on social media
first off we have competitions now I'm
sure all of you have seen posts like tag
a friend who does this or comment or
like to win something and stuff like
that
competitions like these provide great
opportunities for engagement with the
audience and they can be used to
increase your followers to share your
content it could also be for them to
create their own content along with the
predefined hashtag and competitions help
grow your presence on social media
then we have polls and surveys
polls can help you if you need a
collection that also encourages
followers to take action and interact
polls and surveys also provide
opportunities through which you can
learn from customers to understand what
they like about the product or service
or what they don't and to receive their
feedback and then we have videos and
live streams although we'll be covering
this in a little more detail further on
visual storytelling along with videos
and live streams goes a long way to
drive engagement among your audience
these will help get your followers
attention increase trust and credibility
and have a high response rate and has so
much more to offer live stream with its
live nature and having a human face
alongside your business humanizes your
brand and by extension helps increase
customer loyalty and trust and then
there is infographics articles and
images
so social media calendars are successful
because of their ability to increase
collaboration within the team help
understand what works and what doesn't
and in distributing resources in an
effective manner
next up we have number five using social
media marketing tools
social media marketing tools align to
the goals of your organization with it
you can create high quality content
attract new potential customers and
drive engagement and it also helps you
with the planning process you can plan
create and schedule posts on your social
calendar
now some of the more popular social
media tools include buffer HootSuite
buzzsumo if Triple T and much more
now these tools also help with
generating leads creating email lists
finding a relevant audience to show your
content
creating buyer personas providing you
insights on what works and what doesn't
and giving you templates for different
kinds of posts
now for number six visual storytelling
visual storytelling involves passing out
a lot of information in the simplest of
forms visually using pictures and videos
your followers are able to grasp the
message quickly and remember it for a
long time afterwards visual storytelling
is also not limited by language barriers
and this helps it become interesting and
entertaining to anyone watching it can
also help your audience stay interested
and engaged grab the attention of
potential clients and so much more
but it also has some other advantages it
helps you build a bond with your
audience visual storytelling connects
with your audience methods like live
streaming help humanize your brand and
help grow customer loyalty and trust it
has the audience quickly grasp the
intended message thanks to its simple
nature and finally most importantly
content like images and videos are what
go viral with visual storytelling you
increase the chance for your content to
be seen by more potential customers
so have a look at some of our videos so
here's what is machine learning data
science in five minutes and AI in five
minutes now these are some of our most
viewed videos on our Channel and now you
know why visual storytelling if you guys
are interested in watching these videos
you can check them out on our Channel
homepage and we also have similar videos
on blockchain devops and Six Sigma but
now back to the list
let's go to number seven paying for
advertising
this is a method that helps you find a
Target and reach your audience with ease
it can greatly help with achieving your
organization's marketing goal
and this can help you improve your reach
and improve your Brand's visibility it's
pay per click model and shows cost
Effectiveness by providing great results
and return on investment it also helps
improve targeting by letting you control
who sees your ad you get to choose from
a number of different factors like
interests Hobbies personality types
alongside the basic user demographics
like age location gender and so on
now since most social media platforms
have native analytics you also get to
assess and Define the performance of
your ad campaigns
now as great as it sounds there are
certain pitfalls that come along with
peer advertising first of all your
audience could get exposed to your posts
too many times and tune out your content
disregarding it in the process
second it could get really expensive for
small businesses or startups to manage a
campaign to its maximum effectiveness
third people could pass off your content
as irrelevant or unimportant you also
have to deal with a lot of competition
smaller companies with lesser budgets
have more of an uphill battle to deal
with than better funded organizations
next we have number eight news jacking
newsjacking is a method that involves
using current events to promote your own
Brands products and services now it's a
popular method that's used to improve
brand awareness
newsjacking uses the popularity of
current events and drives it to your
brand it helps shine a spotlight on your
products and it also helps you show off
that you are up to date with current
events in the industry and that your
product is relevant and by extension it
also improves engagement and website
traffic
now for number nine a b testing
a b testing is a popular method for
comparing copies creatives and ctas or
call to actions of the posts that you
put on social media now since audiences
would react differently depending on the
content a b testing helps determine
which of the variants your audience
engaged with the most
a b testing can also be performed on
variations of location age gender
education your audience interests and so
on
and next up number 10 community and
influences
joining communities helps your brand
link up with like-minded people and
other companies belonging to your niche
it'll also help you establish your brand
as an authority within the industry
actively participating in these
communities can help create your own
audience of potential brand Advocates to
group up with
and on the other hand partnering up with
influencers helps promote your products
or services to a brand new audience
it helps provide an additional layer of
authenticity in YouTube which is also a
social media platform if you didn't know
here are some very very popular
influencers we have Marcus Brownlee
unbox therapy Mr who's the boss and
Linus Tech tips each of them with more
than 4 million subscribers
and finally we're at number 11.
measuring and analyzing results
accurately tracking and measuring your
marketing efforts are an important part
of the process it ensures that you're
making the most out of your campaigns
now it's really important that you find
key metrics that are crucial for your
brand and these metrics can be tracked
weekly monthly or on a quarterly basis
and based on these results appropriate
actions can be taken
so on Facebook you could look out for
reach and engagement on Twitter you
could look out for impressions
clicks and Impressions and interactions
on LinkedIn and likes comments and
mentions on Instagram and engagements
and Impressions on Pinterest
some of the most popular tools used for
this purpose are Sprout social buffer
HootSuite Google analytics and so on
hello everyone welcome to this new video
by simply learn search engine
optimization has been playing an
essential role in the success of various
businesses for those who are still
looking for growth in the industry and
have search engine optimization
otherwise known as SEO as their primary
weapon then yes you are in the right
place this video on how to rank number
one on Google will give you the best
tips to get a higher ranking without
spending a penny but before we begin
subscribe to our Channel simply learn
and hit the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from Simply learn so before we
begin I have a question for you the
process of getting the quality and
quantity of traffic to your website
organically is known as search engine
marketing search engine optimization
search engine advertising or none of the
above let me know your answers in the
comments section Below in this video
first we will understand why it's
essential to rank high in search engines
next we will have a look at the top five
mantras on how to get ranked number one
on Google search result pages and while
understanding this we will put a light
on why these success tips are important
for getting a good ranking and how we
can actually implement it we will share
some necessary tools to help you carry
out the needed process and stick to the
end of this video to find out the one
thing that can impact your business
tenfold
so definitely we're going to take a look
at the best tips for ranking high on
Google but before that it is necessary
to understand why it's important to rank
high on Google
well we are all aware that most of the
businesses are shifting online nowadays
ranking on search engines has become one
of the most important aspects that
Define the success of a business
the data states that around
1.17 billion people across the globe use
Google search which is estimated to
increase exponentially in the coming
years moreover Google has gained the
trust of their users with their services
over the years this definitely makes the
point of interest to understand why it's
important to rank high on Google search
ranking at the top of search engine
result pages also known as serps allows
a business to generate more traffic to
their website and possibly get more
leads by which then they can get a
chance to convert leads into customers
thereby boosting sales
it also helps in generating authenticity
for your business well not one or two
there are numerous reasons which makes
SEO important to know more about SEO
check the complete playlist on SEO you
can find the link to the playlist in the
description box below
to gain expertise in search engine
optimization get certified as a skilled
SEO professional with simply learns
search engine optimization training
course you can check the course details
from the link in the description box
below as we know how important it is to
rank high on Google so in the next 10
minutes let's get to know the top five
success mantras that will help you rank
high-end Google so the fifth tip on our
list is promote your content whether you
are a business owner or a blogger you
definitely need to promote your content
to get a good audience reach buy content
here we mean data on your website that
can be products services or even a
simple blog to do this find the relevant
groups on the social media platforms
like Facebook or Instagram and post your
content with an excellent call to action
context some blogging or article
submission sites like quora Tumblr and
hub pages may also prove helpful online
forums and communities can be a good
option to spread a word about your
content with people having similar
interests let's focus on our number four
tip internal linking a good site
architecture is always a happy bite for
web crawlers a website with good site
architecture and internal linking helps
web crawlers understand the website
structure and helps them to crawl the
site more effectively the more the pages
of your website are crawled greater are
the chances of getting indexed if pages
are successful indexed they get eligible
for appearing in the search results
let's move to our tip number three yes
it is backlink building any website
linking to your website is a backlink
for your website websites with more
backlinks suggest to the search engine
crawlers that that website has good
content and is trustworthy and should be
ranked higher on the search result pages
to get a backlink the most important
thing is to understand that the da or
the domain authority of the website for
which you are looking for the backlink
is greater than yours getting backlinks
is somewhat entirely a gesture of
Goodwill you can find a page relevant to
your business and ask the website owner
to add the link to your website to the
page in a humble manner you can create a
better or updated version of some other
web content let the site owner know
about it and then ask for a backlink in
a humble way yes you can find some more
relevant backlink building techniques in
the video how to build backlinks check
out the link in the description box
below and number two we have a tip which
is of utmost importance to win a good
position in the search results on page
optimization on-page optimization are
also known as on-page SEO is a process
in which we take essential measures to
improve the website or web pages
position in search engine rankings
on-page optimization is a vast concept
that includes technical optimization of
websites like server speed page loading
speed removing page errors submitting
Pages for indexing and more maintaining
a good website structure and improving
it adding internal and external links on
the site adding SEO optimized images and
video on the page efficient use of
keywords on the page and links and much
more
get the detail guide to learning on-page
optimization by simply learn
check the link in the description box
below and finally the best tip we have
is the most effective one and the one
that rules them all which is keyword
research
keyword research is a process of
identifying and implementing the
relevant keywords for the content you
tend to create
proper keyword research may prove a boon
to your business but it also has the
power to ruin your business so be wise
When selecting your keywords try
choosing long tail keywords if you are
new to the business as these are easier
to rank for you can look at Google's
Auto suggest feature to understand what
people are looking for in your industry
be updated with what your competitors
are doing if something is working for
your competitor there are high chances
that it may work for you as well you can
also take the help of various keyword
research tools like Google's own Keyword
Planner answer the public tool Google
Trends and Etc
these fantastic and 100 practical tips
can drive your business to Heights make
sure you implement all these tips with
more detailed attention as SEO can make
and break you so what according to you
is the most effective way to grow your
business online let us know in the
comments Below in the age of digital
marketing it is very easy to get lost in
the sea of information if you are a
beginner you will probably spend a lot
of time reading and researching even if
you are an expert you will still need to
keep up to date and know what's going on
in the marketing world but how do you
find the time to do that how do you find
the time to stay on top of Trends and
Innovations we have compiled a list of
20 plus digital marketing tools to help
you make your life easier
some of these tools might sound familiar
to you and some might sound new and
interesting we believe all of them have
some value in your life and can assist
you in staying on top of trends hey
everyone I am tusha badiwal welcome to
Simply learns YouTube channel in this
video we will understand 20 plus digital
marketing tools to grow your business in
2022 but before we begin if you enjoy
watching Tech related content consider
subscribing to our YouTube channel and
hitting that Bell icon to stay tuned
so without any further delay let's get
started with the plan for today's
session first we will look at the
research part next we will explore tools
to build or host the website content is
king So next we will have a look at some
of the best content creation tools to
grow your business
moving forward we will discuss designing
and Graphics tools once designing is
done it's time to promote and hence we
will look at the best promotional tools
after that we will discuss some great
email marketing tools user behavior and
competitor analysis tools and finally we
will end the session by understanding
the communication tools that will help
your business operate smoothly
research research is one of the most
essential parts of getting your business
to the next level it's what turns an
idea into a real business however it is
hard to do research without the right
tools luckily there are many tools out
there that do the job perfectly here are
just few that you need to know about
Uber suggest Uber suggest is a free tool
that produces fresh keyword ideas it is
among the best free tools available on
the market however it has a Premium plan
for advanced features but it is best if
you are starting out and it has some
good features like you will get the
search volume for free keyword ideas and
content ideas
Keyword Planner it is one of the best
free tools and the best part is that
it's a Google product so that the data
can be trusted you can use Google
Keyword Planner to do keyword research
Google Keyword Planner will show you the
monthly search volume of keywords and
phrases the average cost per click in
your selected country and how difficult
it is to rank for the keywords some of
the best features are you will get the
custom time based keyword data and get
to know the competition on that keyword
hrefs hrefs is one of the most advanced
tool available for keyword research it
is also used for competitor analysis
rank tracking and site auditing href's
main features are geared towards
marketer but you can also use it to find
keywords for Google YouTube and Amazon
the tool is paid but suitable for
businesses looking for in-depth
information it has some features like
rank tracker that will help you know
your existing website ranking and the
second one is alert you will get
important information or stats by mail
after doing the research part you need a
website for your business let's have a
look at how to do that the first step in
creating a website is to find a place to
host it there are many options out there
and depending on what your site will be
used for you may need different tools
web hosting tools have evolved to meet
the online communities need better it
can be challenging to select the right
one through many options here are the
few of the best tools available on the
market
WordPress it will help you create your
website by just drag and dropping no
coding is required also it has a lot of
plugins that can be used according to
your website needs blogger you can
create a beautiful blog using blogger
for free and it is also has free themes
which you can use
still it is always recommended that you
use tools like WordPress to build your
website because businesses need a
website with lot of functionalities and
WordPress makes this process easier
the website requires hosting as the next
tool we have is hostinger you need to
purchase a domain and hosting to host a
website there are other companies also
available that you can use to host your
site such as GoDaddy HostGator Etc
hostinjure provides automatic backups
that will ensure that your website data
is secured it allows you to create
unlimited subdomain which is also
necessary for a business website
for free hosting and free domains you
can use Infinity free but for a business
website it is always recommended to go
with the paid hosting because this will
give your customer a good experience
when they visit your website but for
beginner just wanting to learn how
website hosting works you can use
Infinity free
every Business website and its social
media platform need content and content
is the oxygen of the internet there is
no surviving without it but meeting the
demand of a Content hungry World often
means that you are forced to pull your
hair out only to throw more into the
fire
from research to Creation to
distribution content is now 24x7 job
requiring many internal resources or
costly outsourced help if you are
looking to cut down the cost and
streamline your efforts here are some
content creation tools to take your
business to the next level
headline it is an AI tool that will
create a landing page automatically no
writing designing and coding is required
you need to give information about the
product and it is also has built-in
templates to use it became famous
because of this feature but now it is
upgraded and you will see a lot of other
features that will help you create
excellent content it is a paid tool but
you can try its free version
pepper type it is a One-Stop AI solution
tool for all content needs and the best
part is you will get 10 000 word limit
to try out this fantastic tool the
specialty of this tool is that it allows
you to create content for specific
social media platforms and long form
content
grammarly grammarly is a free online
tool that find mistakes in your writing
and suggest improvements as you write
grammarly will underline any mistakes
you have made and offer suggestions on
how to fix them
additionally it has a plagiarism Checker
and a punctuation checker
however for additional features you need
to go with grammarly premium
the best way to create excellent content
is to have good visuals this is why we
have listed the best designing tools
that you can use to get stock images and
videos
canva you can design your website using
canva for free it is the best tool to
make your website content more engaging
it is a simple drag and drop tool that
allows you to create beautiful Graphics
Flyers infographics social media post
and more you can also use it to create
more engaging images for your post
furthermore it gives you free templates
and allows you to collaborate with your
business team using team functionality
pixabay pixabay is a free website or a
creative community that shares copyright
free photos illustrations music and
videos
all pixabay content are licensed under
the pixaby license you can use them
without asking for permission or
crediting the artist even for commercial
purposes
you can download these stock images
videos musics and illustration without
signing up
Shutterstock although it also comes with
the same feature the key difference is
that it is paid you might wonder why to
use this shutter stock since we already
have a free tool like pixabay well it
depends on your business needs there are
some images and stock footage that you
will only find on certain stock in
addition set a stock has powerful
editing tools and custom size options
that attract people
now we have a better understanding of
the content part in order to attract
more visitors the content needs to be
promoted the following tools will help
you promote your business Drive traffic
to your website convert visitors into
leads build brand awareness Etc
Google ads Google ads are a powerful
tool that can help you reach your target
audience it is small but significant
step towards online Success Through many
people believe that Google ads are not
as effective as they used to be there
are still more benefits than drawbacks
the only thing you need to know how to
use it your website can be advertised
via Google ads and your product and
services can be promoted on YouTube it
has an excellent feature lead form
extension that allow user to provide
their contact details directly through
the ad without visiting your landing
page additionally Live Events targeting
for example graduating from a college is
also a great feature since it helps you
reach the correct type of audience
Facebook ads manager it allows you to
run Facebook and Instagram ads and it's
an excellent way to promote your
business a feature like Facebook
analytics will give you a good grasp of
data feature like audience Insight will
better understand who is interested in
your product and services
Google ads and Facebook ads require you
to spend money on ads by setting up a
daily or a custom budget
is a Content marketing tool to help you
find the best ways of engaging creating
and spreading content across social and
search channels two of the best feature
is finding an influencer that will help
you to find the right influencer and a
Content Discovery feature which will
help you to discover new content ideas
email marketing tools are the most
effective means to stay in touch with
your customers you can nurture leads
rearrange with your audience and build a
subscriber base through email businesses
today recognize the importance of email
and marketers are investing heavily in
email marketing tools however in the
overwhelming sea of email marketing
tools finding the right fit can be
tricky we have selected some of the best
email marketing tools to help your
business get started and grow through
MailChimp MailChimp is a comprehensive
marketing platform that lets you keep
track of and communicate with your
clients customers and other interested
parties but it is popular because of its
email Services there is a free plan of
MailChimp the free plan is often more
than enough for small businesses up to
2000 subscribers can be added and 12 000
emails can be sent a month it supports
multiple integration to integrate other
third-party softwares and MailChimp also
allows you to update or remove the
subscriber profiles which is also one of
the best feature of MailChimp send in
blue it is very similar to MailChimp
both have excellent and similar features
when it comes to email Services one
unique feature of sending blue is that
it has the option of a drag and drop
Builder that is accessible by mobile
analysis and optimization businesses
need to analyze and optimize their
processes to grow furthermore you should
analyze the data to develop a solution
to the problems in your industry several
tools can be beneficial here let's
discuss that
Google search console this tool will
help you understand how your website
performs on Google searches by ranking
on top you will have higher chances of
attracting more visitors the index
coverage report will help you understand
which web page have problems moreover it
has a very useful URL inspection tool
which gives information about Google's
indexed page version
with IQ many YouTubers majorly use it to
analyze their performance on YouTube and
optimize their Channel if you are
looking to rank your video on YouTube
you need to optimize the title
description and tags this tool helps you
to do that
the tool includes a thumbnail generator
that lets you create customized
thumbnails that generate good views and
it has Trend alerts which will notify
you by email of popular content
Google analytics using Google analytics
you can track the traffic on your
website and find out where your visitors
are coming from it also allows you to
track your sales performance and traffic
sources
Google analytics is a tool that will let
you know if your website is performing
well and also if you need to make some
changes to improve its performance
it has outstanding features like funnel
analysis and smart goals a funnel is a
method for determining which steps are
necessary to achieve the desired
outcomes and with smart goals you can
identify and count the most engaged
users on your website user Behavior user
Behavior tools help you understand user
behavior on the website user Behavior
tools are very effective tools used in
digital marketing to track the behavior
of visitors and make the business more
effective
below are the sum of the user Behavior
tools used in digital marketing
hot job hotja is an inside tool that
lets you analyze your customer behavior
and get feedback to understand them
better and come up with new business
strategies to grow your business
this tool gives you visual feedback
which you won't find in other tools and
it also offers surveys which is also a
unique feature of our job smart look it
is mostly similar to hot jaw but it has
some additional features like
customizable dashboard and conversion
funnel which means the visualization of
how people follow the path
competitor analysis many businesses
start their competitive study when
planning their digital marketing
strategy and then abandon it
it is essential to make adjustments
after competitor analysis and use great
tools here are some of the best
the tool is completely paid you can use
this tool to improve your PPC campaign
as it gives you insight into what your
competitors are doing keywords can also
be imported as well as downloaded social
blade it is used for social media
monitoring and influencer tracking for
example you can get lot of information
about the performance of other
competitors and how they are doing on
YouTube and other social media channels
the best part is that many features are
available in the free plan
similar web it is also an excellent tool
to analyze competitors website traffic
and you can also get the Google Play and
Apple App Store data
href we already covered this in the
research category but we wanted to
mention it here because href will also
be viewed as one of the best tools for
analyzing competitors
communication
starting and building a successful
business require better communication
within your team we must ensure that our
task has been clearly communicated to
the team so that we will be able to
perform the work as we intended thus one
needs a tool to accomplish that so now
let's check out some of the best tools
for communication
slack the app is a chat room that brings
together all of your team's
Communication in one place meaning there
is a no longer a need to use email Skype
or multi-chat room apps slack can be
used with both work and personal
accounts and it can benefit businesses
in several different ways
Microsoft teams it is also similar to
slack but it offers unlimited app
integration and unlimited chat messages
there are free plans for both but you
can upgrade if your business need aren't
met
here what you have learned so far
initially we discussed research then
tools to build and host the website next
we discussed content creation and
graphic designing tools after that we
discuss tools that will help in the
promotion and then the email marketing
tools after that we discussed analysis
and optimization tools
next we discussed user behavior and
competitor analysis tools and finally we
discuss the communication tools so here
we wrap up the basics in digital
marketing if you like this video
consider subscribing to our Channel and
hit the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from Simply learn if you have
any question put down in the comment
sections and our experts will be happy
to answer your questions stay tuned with
simply learn till we meet again thanks
for watching
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here